Three,
two.
Hello Carl.
Hello,
Joe Rogan.
Good to see you again buddy.
Good to see you too.
Is like Deja Vu.
It was,
I think it was eight months ago or so.
Then I was on the podcast wasn't and it
flew like that.
Yeah,
it does fly like that.
Yeah.
That's kind of scary.
A little too quick.
Yeah.
I just turned 30 and 40 before you know
it.
Well,
I was going to say 30 was the first one
where I ever really stopped like 30
minutes before I turned 30.
I actually took a moment and I was like,
okay,
you're 29.
Enjoy your last 30 minutes of being 29
and when I hit 30 it was the first
little inkling of.
I guess this is kind of what a midlife
crisis feels like because I have a three
in front now and I'm not really not
comfortable with that because I feel
like I'm still a fucking 19 year old,
you know?
Well it's a weird thing to be obsessed
with your,
your.
It's an inevitable progression.
Like to be obsessed with youth.
Yeah.
I love being in my twenties.
Well,
why would you love something that's
going to go away real quick?
Yeah,
it's going to get old.
It's nothing you can do about it.
Just stay healthy.
Yeah,
and people who fight it,
it's always easy to tell that when they
go get plastic surgery and stuff.
If you.
If you do like one plastic surgery,
sometimes somebody could get away with
it,
but if you do multiple,
all everybody knows almost immediately.
You ever watched that show?
Botched.
I didn't know.
I just started getting into it.
I accidentally watched it.
I turned the TV on and it was just on
like when I turned the TV on and I was
like,
what in the fuck?
And this lady was getting her nose
repaired because it had collapsed
because she had gotten so many plastic
surgeries on her nose that are sinus had
caved in so they had to take a chunk of
her rib proper knows,
but then then the,
the tissue inside was dying.
One of those guys wants to come on.
They found out we were talking about it.
So he wants to,
I don't know how many times can you talk
about plastic surgery,
Dr.
patient.
Not Patient fucked up,
but what's the doctor going to try to do
pitch your audience on getting to know
the opposite?
I think he's probably against the repair
guy.
Oh,
so what shows about repairing people
that fucked up and you know,
it looks so primitive to when you see
how they do it,
like the way that they do.
I noticed this about wisdom teeth when I
got my wisdom teeth pulled out,
they literally just go in there like you
would expect for like a car repair and
they're just like,
all right,
time to rip it out.
And you see them like leaning on him
pulling it and you're like,
oh I thought this was more advanced than
this,
but it's really not step on your cheek.
And I actually went under for my wisdom
teeth because I've heard.
I know I'm such a bitch,
but I,
I thought so.
I guess I got the Michael Jackson stuff,
the propofol.
I think it was,
I was,
it was a nice.
It's weird because you just,
they tell you to like count back down
from 100 and 199 and I remember stop.
Oh my God,
that's so terrible.
That's knee surgery.
What is going on here?
What stock?
Whatever the fuck they put in as Neiman
and he's trying to get it out.
Oh my Jesus.
Oh cool.
So yeah,
the moral of the story is we actually
don't know what we're doing as human
beings and we're still obviously very
primitive.
Even the advanced stuff is super
That's what that shows.
Well,
I don't know,
maybe that guy just fucked up.
I don't,
I don't think I've ever seen that
before.
But isn't it for everything?
Like even with those jobs,
don't they do the same thing?
Like Oh,
we're going to chisel down the nose so
they have to take like a fricking sander
or something and just do it.
Yeah.
I had my deviated septum fixed and then
they have to pack it.
They pack it full of stuff and so you're
all clogged up and they took big chunks
of the bone out of the inside because
what do they call it?
Turbinates or something like that.
I had a bunch of scar tissue
calcification here.
Sees when someone has cauliflower ears.
Yes.
Yeah.
Fighters.
Usually you get that in your nose too if
your nose has been broken a bunch of
times because what?
What?
That cauliflower ear is his blood under
the surface of the skin calcifies and it
becomes essentially a rock.
Have you touched someone's California
in?
It's literally like there's a rock in
there.
It's really kind of crazy.
Will you get that inside your nose to
when your nose had been broken a bunch
of times and it bleeds in the inside the
tissue and then it turns into this
really hard thing that blocks all your
sinuses,
so if you put a hole in it,
what happens?
It's a rock.
Okay.
It's calcium rock.
Have you ever seen those videos of like
cysts when they drain the cysts?
Do you ever see that lady's a instagram
page Dr?
Pimp?
No,
because I don't want to throw up.
You need to go to Dr Pepper.
He's going to do it.
Isn't he doing it?
She's great.
She's hilarious too.
She.
She like.
She loves it.
She thinks and fun.
I bet you get to a zillion views to.
Oh my God,
she's got more instagram followers than
me,
I think.
Wow.
How many?
She got point nine while she doesn't
have as many as me,
but she is.
She has a lot.
Did you ever have bad acne at any point
in your life?
I had some pretty decent acne when I was
in high school or get a good one.
How about that one?
It.
Yeah,
that one.
When you had your cursor on try that
one.
That one looks like they're going to
open that sucker up.
Don't nothing.
Nothing.
Let's keep going.
Still going.
That ain't shit.
Okay.
I will say that it's a nightmare once.
Let's find some other ones.
Jamie.
The Look of that is disgusting,
but I think it's universally agreed upon
that the feel of getting a big pimple
and popping it properly.
It feels amazing.
Look at this.
Some sort of a cyst.
Someone's head.
Oh,
can you stop it?
Yeah.
He's got a bulging system.
Looks like a fucking eyeball dude.
Oh,
it's like a marble.
Oh my God.
I'm never good again.
Elite again.
You'll fine.
Oh,
I just want to eat any cysts.
Yeah.
That's like the side of someone's head
weight and it didn't even actually like
totally pop out either.
While those things are stuck,
I mean that's part of your skin's
protein tissue.
I used to have pretty bad acne when I
was younger and I had accutane.
They gave me accutane and that stuff
worked.
I mean they say that there's a small
chance that like I guess in maybe one
percent or point,
oh,
one percent of cases.
Some people got depression and so they
said there's a risk of suicide with
this,
but I never.
It never affected me in that way at all.
And it really just zonked your sebaceous
glands and your just good.
Like it just,
it's almost a cure.
Yeah.
My friend Andrew Santina had it for the
same reason,
but he said he got the side effect is
there.
He did,
yeah.
On one hand it was amazing because the
skin cleared up and the other hand he's
never felt so bad and it's alive.
Wow.
Yeah,
but you don't know what to do because
you feel bad if you have acne,
feel bad if you take the medication,
but the medication will knock out all
the acne.
Well,
I also take,
I don't take accutane anymore,
but I actually take finasteride for hair
and they say trump takes that to.
And then there were some doctors,
I don't know how credible this is,
where there were some doctors who were
like,
that stuff is not that great in terms of
mental health.
No,
that's Propecia,
propecia and the same thing,
same thing in inhibits
dihydrotestosterone,
which does cause depression and some
people I think are,
are he said that his depression was
linked to when he started taking
propecia.
I take it.
I don't,
I've never.
It's never affected me that way.
It decreases your testosterone though.
Kills Your boners.
Well,
mine are all right there.
All right.
How would they be if you didn't take it?
I guess double or triple.
You tell me.
I don't know,
but the thing is I wouldn't look good.
I feel like you really pull off a bald
head very nicely.
Whereas I'd look like a leukemia
patient.
Do you think so?
I do get a decent sized head dude.
I mean,
come on.
I wouldn't look good,
but look at me.
First of all,
I would have to go to the gym way more
than I do now and I'd have to get
tattoos everywhere to look.
Yeah,
if you want to look like a bad ass with
a bald head,
of course you do.
There's this guy,
there's this wrestler for Wwe,
I forget his name,
but he had really long greasy hair,
like the typical wrestler hair.
And then he recently decided to shave
his head and he pulled it off nicely.
It looks way better with a bald head.
He had,
um,
he,
he's just one of those guys where you
looked gross with the really long hair
that was greasy.
But when you got,
when you went bald,
okay,
now you look normal.
That Greasy Harrison new thing.
It's like the John Wick hair greasiness
in the hair.
Yeah.
When remember when Keanu reeves was John
Wick,
it was always greasy.
I don't remember that.
No,
it's a good movie to listen to or watch
rather when you're on the treadmill.
This is doing a cardio challenge,
a good one tag.
Greasy.
But it seems like Gel people make fun of
me because Gel they say uh,
so like 19 nineties and I'm still
wearing it.
Creature of habit.
It's just chill.
It's available.
People will make fun of you for
everything.
That's true.
Yeah.
Give them a chance,
dude.
I did a powder on my face the other day
because I was under these lights and I
did feel silly as I put it on.
It's a little weird.
Like,
why can't I just be shining?
Yeah.
What's going on?
People terrified of sweat.
Yeah.
The problem to me was pasty and shiny,
so super white and shiny and it just
looked gross.
It looks like I'm unhealthy.
So of you were like a bronze bronze.
That's slightly better but still kinda
gross.
So you were saying that you got into it?
Well you asked Chris Christie something.
Oh yeah.
Political,
political or what is political as Jamie
was saying,
it's like comicon for political dorks.
Exactly.
That's exactly correct.
Yeah,
and it's weird because what they do,
Joe,
is they invite like,
um,
like establishment media figures and
some politicians,
but then they also invite new media
figures like me and our worlds do not
mix.
Yeah.
In fact,
many of them,
I don't even think many of them knew who
I was.
Meanwhile,
when you actually go to the people who
were there,
you know,
it was all the new media people who are
getting the most attention,
right?
Where you have guys like Bill Kristol
walking around who was in the Bush
administration and people are like,
who?
Who are you?
So it's a very weird thing going on
there.
Well,
Kudos to them for recognizing that new
media has such a place and it's just
media.
I mean at this point I think that this
whole concept of new media versus obese,
it's just media,
but there's independent,
uncensored untethered media,
which is why one more popular.
Yeah,
of course.
exactly.
Tribe watching one of those ABC
nightline or one of those fucking
political shows,
terror and then try watching something
on youtube where people get to be free
with their language and free with their
expression,
not beholden to any executives are
producers and yeah,
so they get it but they don't get it,
get it.
Because when I went to the Chris
Christie thing,
they had it in this giant room and about
25 percent of the room was full and then
for one of my debates that I did a few
panels but one debate,
they put me in like the smallest room
and we had all the seats full and people
standing up and packing the room so they
get it but they don't get it.
Get it to,
to them,
the new media people are kind of like an
afterthought.
Like okay,
we'll have them because you know,
they should be here,
but they don't.
They don't realize that the draw is not
Chris Christie.
The draws,
the new media people.
Well Chris Christie and that's not just
me,
but I just wanted to clear up under
anymore.
He's not.
I mean like who is he?
Why would they think that he could fill
a place because he's been on tv a lot,
but I want to be clear.
I'm not even just saying,
oh,
leftwing new media,
which obviously is what I would be,
but even the Ben Shapiro types,
of course he has a big audience when he
comes.
He's got a giant.
Yes,
exactly,
but it's so.
It's all the new media people who are
popular and the rest of them are not.
Did you go to some sort of a concert
while you were there?
Oh No,
this is.
But they gave you.
This is how you got in the building
without them giving you a hard time to
keep it forever.
No,
I just haven't.
I didn't think about snipping it off
yet,
but now I'm wishing I did because we
were talking about it.
There's some dorks that go to coachella
and they keep the fucking thing.
Yeah.
No,
this is.
This is coming off soon.
I'll tell you.
Not Scared to
take that big ass knife.
I'll cut off a finger by accident if I
use that thing.
It'd be fun.
Just so everybody knows,
this is what I'm talking about.
Jamie just gave you a pair of scissors
if you want those.
Oh yeah,
I'll do that.
So anyway,
don't take it off under pressure me if
you want to keep it on.
I'm not a bracelet guy in the first
place.
So that's a weird thing to be a bracelet
guy.
Like a lot of beads,
like you're really trying hard to be
spiritual.
Here we go and that's not me or ice.
If you want a diamond it up.
Like if you're a rapper and you and a
lot of ice on your wrist.
I did use to wear earrings.
I did use to do that.
And I see in your face that you want to
mock me at this moment I had earrings.
Oh you did?
You probably had the old nineties hoop
earrings.
I had a hoop and a diamond stud,
but it wasn't even a diamond.
It was a cubic Zirconia.
Yeah.
And has it ever happened in the history
of the world that you know,
a,
a woman has walked up to a man and said
to a man,
you know,
I wasn't attracted to you,
but then I saw your earring probably
happened in the eighties.
Somebody probably said something like
that in the eighties.
Just just because you're so bold,
you've got a hole in your ear.
Took a chance.
Yeah.
I guess that had a counter culture vibe
to it.
You hearing little cutie man,
you had a baby face know the other
things just to earpiece.
That's a hook.
That's the thing that goes back to hold
it in place.
So you only had it on one ear.
On the left hand side,
it didn't go like full rockstar with a
double hoops.
Axl Rose Word on the street is that if
you only do the right ear,
you're supposed to be a signal that
you're gay.
That was the word at one point in time.
But is that true or is that just people
talking?
Shit.
Oh,
I don't know.
I had it on my left ear because that's
what I had heard.
I remember that too,
like don't you,
if you could do both and that's not
considered gay,
but if you did the right ear alone,
that was considered good,
but if you did both,
either a pirate or you're in a band.
I did have both at one point and it's
funny because when people see old
pictures of me,
they say I either look like the Jersey,
like a jersey shore wannabe or like a
backstreet boys wanted me because I
looked because I had the earrings in and
I had the hair totally spiked and yeah,
that was the style at the time.
While you're also running a risk because
you've got like a little bit of facial
hair.
Yeah.
I don't have a very masculine.
No a beard,
but you've got something going on.
You're definitely a man or a woman
undergoing hormone replacement therapy.
You got that Chaz Bono type thing.
It's um,
this is called a lazy man's beard
because I can't even even really grow a
beard.
So it's just this is what it is when I
get lazy.
You got a little something going on
though?
Yeah,
I guess so.
Maybe it's the finasteride just had the
mustache itself.
That would be kind of creepy.
No mustaches.
I'm going on a jihad against mustache
because I think for whatever reason they
look more ridiculous than full facial
hair.
I don't know why.
Some people like,
like Sam Elliott,
the actor.
I don't know who that is.
I know.
I know Tom Selleck.
I've seen roadhouse,
but which guy is it enrolled?
Everybody knows who.
It's not the main character of Patrick
swayze.
Oh my.
Yeah,
but he's got the.
He's got the mustache.
What a man.
But the GRANDPA vibe going on,
but he didn't always go to roadhouse.
Go to look at that.
Sam Elliott and.
Yeah,
but he's a great voice.
Nobody's blowing him because he has a
mustache.
Easy blow his fucking game area.
So look,
get that.
Come on.
I mean the one.
Love it with the hair right now there.
Are there that semen roadhouse?
Yeah,
but that's a full beard.
That's more of a full beard.
That's true.
And that looks better on him.
I don't know that.
Oh,
come on now.
I don't think a go to that one right
there.
I don't think a goatee looks as
ridiculous as a mustache alone.
Some guys can pull it off,
you know?
It's a bold choice,
but he can't look.
You can't look overly artsy with it.
You know what I mean?
You can't or you can't.
No,
you can't.
If you're,
if it looks like you're tied to your
goatee as a matter of your identity,
then it's a problem.
But if it's just a dude who seems like
he's rocking a goatee,
he just decided one day to rock a
goatee,
then it's all right.
You know what kind of died out the soul
patch,
the soul patch.
Yeah.
I haven't seen one of those in forever.
You know,
that kind of went away.
Did you ever have any facial hair or.
No,
just beard beards.
I grew it way out at one point in time
because,
uh,
there's a guy named Evan Tanner who was
an mma fighter that was known for having
a big,
thick,
crazy beard.
He was a really interesting guy and he
really nice guy too.
And he died in.
He went on sort of a walkabout and
decided to go in death valley and camp
out and um,
he ran out of water.
I couldn't find his water and dying from
heat and a lot of us were pretty broken
up about it.
So a bunch of people online decided to
grow out our beards for a certain amount
of months.
That's me with a full beard.
Wow.
So you get a almost.
You could get a cave man.
Beard going if you wanted to.
Yeah,
I get a full beard.
Yeah.
And that's me trimming around the cheeks
because my shit creeps all the way up to
my nostrils.
Yeah.
I grew that out for a couple months.
I forget how long we decided to grow.
What are you doing?
Listen,
that was when he wanted to play Robert
Shapiro didn't need to do that for the
Oj movie.
I feel like it was okay.
Maybe it's just,
yeah,
that this verifies every single,
you know,
whisper about John Travolta,
tickle a Baltic or it is just a,
it's right there for typically involves.
Anyway,
so the Chris Christie thing.
Yeah.
So I'm in Politiken.
He's what?
What was he doing exactly?
There you are.
Yeah.
You want.
You can play it if you want.
Okay,
please.
Kyle questions.
Chris Christie,
anti marijuana.
Watched
that clip like 40 times over.
You pause that for a second.
I just wanna explain that to Joe.
I don't know if you know what I'm
referencing there,
but during the Republican primary there
was one debate where Chris Christie just
totally destroyed Marco Rubio's chances
of becoming president because he kept
repeating himself over and over,
giving the same talking points and Chris
Christie pointed that out and then Mark
Rubio did it again and Chris,
Chris,
he was like,
there he goes again.
There he goes again,
and the room exploded.
And it was that interaction where
everybody where Rubio tanked in the
polls and finished him off.
So my strategy with Christie was,
I'm going to start this off by giving
them credit on something to disarm him,
and then I'm gonna hit him with the real
question for a sport
in regards to the opioid epidemic,
you care deeply about that generation
to,
to study in the Journal of the American
Medical Association,
legal,
recreational.
Marijuana would help fight the opioid
epidemic,
so knowing that and knowing that 62
percent of Americans now favor,
favor full legalization,
why not supportive
play out,
let it play
epidemiological studies from Harvard
Medical School for Stanford to tell you
the exact opposite.
Okay.
Pause right there.
His giant problems with epidemiology
studies and he should know that.
Yeah,
so my studies for sure,
epidemic epidemiology studies that
basically a questionnaires,
you know,
you don't,
you don't take into account all sorts of
other issues that these people do in
their lives and also like when when
you're dealing with those kinds of
studies,
a person could be doing marijuana but
also be drinking a lot but also be doing
other things.
So if what the argument is that it's a
gateway drug,
the only way that argument works is if
you somehow or another track someone and
saw that marijuana made them change
their opinion on doing other drugs
because a lot of these people are just
doing drugs and they do marijuana as
well.
Shouldn't say,
well look,
we've shown these through these
epidemiology studies that marijuana is a
gateway drug because they started
smoking marijuana and then they went to
do heroin.
They probably were going to do heroin
anyway.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's really what's going on.
Sure.
There's no fucking gateway drug.
That whole idea has been dismissed.
That's like saying water is a gateway
drug to rape every rapist,
drinks,
water,
you know?
It really is the almost that stupid.
So do you think that when there was a
little bit of applause,
because he answered me quickly,
do you think that that beginning of the
applause was for my question or for him?
Him saying no and respond hundred
percent for you because we were debating
that.
I wasn't sure.
Now let's do it again.
Play it again.
It's really clear.
Why not?
I,
I couldn't tell epidemiological
studies for both Harvard Medical Schools
here in this effort,
Stafford,
that tell you the exact opposite and say
that marijuana is still a gateway drug
and that people who try marijuana
between the ages of 14 and 18 are three
times more likely three times more
likely to try opioids or
methamphetamines than people who don't,
and I just don't believe that what we're
in the midst of a drug addiction crisis
that we need to legalize and other
drugs.
Clearly he's got a food addiction.
Food addiction is far more dangerous
than marijuana.
Marijuana on its own has killed.
No one ever.
Half a million people die every year
from being a fat fuck.
That's.
That's the facts.
Yeah.
This guy is a part of a real death
epidemic and if you were mean,
you would bring that up.
This motherfucker brings a fucking bank
robber size bag of m and m's to a
football game.
He's ridiculous.
Talking about marijuana and marijuana
being a gateway drug.
The whole idea of it is stupid like
smoke marijuana or don't smoke
marijuana,
but the point is marijuana doesn't kill
you.
It's really that simple.
Now,
if you're saying that marijuana causes
you to do all sorts of other things,
you've got to have some direct pathway
that shows that it changes your
inhibitions.
It changes the way you think about
things.
That's never been done.
If anything,
what gets people to try drugs is when
you tell them that marijuana is
dangerous and then they smoke marijuana
and go,
this is Shane dangerous not doing to me.
I feel great the next day.
There's nothing wrong.
All it does eat a pizza.
You know,
I got a giggle.
I watched a bunch of cartoons.
My friends.
We had a great fucking time.
That is the misinformation aspect of it
is more dangerous than the idea that
it's a kate.
Some sort of a gateway.
I agree with all of that.
Now.
I wanted to pounce when he said that,
but you have to understand this was his
town hall,
so I knew that I was.
First of all,
I was going to be shoved to the side
very quickly anyway because there was a
whole big line behind me.
It'd be wrong about people clapping.
They might have really clear,
he said that was wrong.
I'm sure some of the people in the room
were there to see him and they agree
with him because it was his town hall,
but I wanted to pounce,
but I knew I can't really go back and
forth like it's a debate.
So what I did is whenever I knew I could
interject just a little bit,
I pushed him on it.
And you're gonna see that in a second.
What is a weird background with like a
bird?
It's in 19 eighties.
Backdrop that they put up,
but what is it?
What does it say?
It's as political as it says.
Polydoconol with a weird.
A weird drawing is weird,
right?
Yeah.
Okay.
But I wouldn't what we do alcohol,
toothpaste back in the tube.
And that's a big important article about
marijuana because once you legalize this
goes back to the two.
You can't do it because we tried.
It's called prohibition and it didn't
work.
She didn't stay legal in California
because it's fine.
Listen,
I hit the states,
have the right to do what they want to
do on this,
but.
But what I would tell you is that broad
legalization of marijuana,
in my view,
to alleviate or even minimize your
current prices and in fact in some ways
may add to it,
and I will also say that I almost never
agreed with the teacher's union in any
state anywhere,
but the Colorado Education Association
has said this year that the single
biggest challenge for their members to
educate middle schoolers and high
schoolers in Colorado legalized
marijuana,
that kids are coming with gummy bears
and other types of edibles and their
high school,
their high,
the good part of the time,
and it's making it much more difficult
for them to teach.
That's the Colorado Education
Association.
You,
I'm sure at this very moment,
if they were watching,
will be appalled to know that.
I agree with that.
I agree with them on that,
but it.
I respectfully disagree with your point
of view.
Thank you sir.
So he actually changed his position
slightly because when he ran for
president he said,
not only am I against marijuana being
illegal at a federal level,
I wouldn't even let the individual
states decide whether or not they want
legal marijuana.
So in other words,
he would prosecute the states like
Colorado and California that have legal
marijuana using federal law.
And right there he softened his position
slightly and he said,
well,
leave it up to the states and let them
decide.
So anything that's because he knows
he'll never be president.
No,
I think he still wants to be president.
There's no fucking way I think he's
going to run again.
No,
I don't know if he's going to run in 20
slash 20,
but 20 slash 20 for some serious.
First of all,
the uh,
the odds of that guy's going to make it
eight more years with that fair point.
Morbidly obese carcass.
He's moving his hand around with does it
need get a stapler?
Didn't he get his stomach fucking suit?
You know,
somebody pointed that out.
I didn't know that.
I never saw those stories.
I'm not denying that it's true,
but I just never heard it.
But if he did,
it didn't work while I had a friend who
ate through two of those.
He,
he,
uh,
when you're a d,
that's what I'm saying anyway,
about food.
He's addicted to food that's like,
this is unquestionably,
he's an addict.
Do you think anybody's said that to him
in his life or an I look.
Look how much thinner you go.
Okay.
And he did this.
Oh,
I guess he did this before the
presidential race because he wanted to
make it.
But then he got fat again.
Yeah.
So he was wrote ton before.
He was like a bag of water before and
then you know,
he,
he trimmed himself down.
Yeah.
And it's funny because I don't think in
any way he realizes the hypocrisy of
having his own,
um,
you know,
issue with food and he would argue,
hey man,
listen,
I'm going to eat what I want it to
freedom choice.
But when comes to freedom for somebody
to decide to tweak their consciousness
slightly,
all of a sudden he says,
you shouldn't be allowed to do that.
Well,
that's where it's preposterous.
The idea that you mean even with what he
said about alcohol didn't make any
sense.
Like would you make alcohol illegal?
What we try to read,
it's called prohibition.
Okay,
but let's pretend that you had some sort
of an ability to keep that from going
sideways.
Again,
let's start from the beginning.
Would you want alcohol to be legal or
not?
If you could wave your hand and and
there would be no more problems that are
alcohol associated.
Would you do that and make it illegal
versus give a grown adult the
possibility of deciding whether or not
they want to drink or not drink?
Yeah.
He's not being consistent and his logic,
that's the point is that he's willing to
say I'm thinking about donuts,
but he even.
He even mentioned prohibition there,
but that makes my point,
not his point.
Yes,
because that's when the mafia got
incredibly powerful because you pushed
all the alcohol sales underground and
they got all the power and the money is
a result of it and that's when crime a
shot through the roof.
So if you want to decrease violent crime
and the drug war.
Yeah,
I mean,
look,
we talked to people in Mexico and the
United States and our hunger for illegal
drugs is a reason why the cartel got so
huge when we were kids.
When I was in high school,
there was no Mexican cartel.
Yeah.
It was never discussed.
It was not an issue.
There was no discussion whatsoever about
violence from Mexico.
That is an incredibly recent thing.
In fact,
I did MTV spring break,
I want to say it was back in 2002.
I was hosting this spring break thing
for MTV when fear factor was just on the
air and it was like one of those
publicity things that we did and there
was no worries about going to Mexico.
Mexico 10 was nothing.
It was just like,
hey,
we're going to Mexico.
Okay,
cool.
It's like,
hey,
we're going to go to new.
Mexico was no different.
Yeah.
You know,
and now it's like you're going to
Mexico.
What about the gangs?
What about the violence would have put
the cartel people would go to Tijuana
all the time.
And you would worry because it was seedy
and crazy and you know,
it was a lot of pickpockets and thieves,
but it was never cartel violence.
Cartel violence is literally within the
last 15 years or so,
and our strategy had the opposite of the
effect they wanted.
So you get rid of El Chapo and you
think,
okay,
if the decapitation strategy,
we got rid of the top guy,
now we're good.
But what happened is you had his cartel
became fractionalized and then you had
people fighting who were top officials
in his cartel and they both wanted to
become the head guy.
And so then there's a war between those
guys and their gangs in the street.
So it's the exact opposite of what they
say they want,
which is let's decrease the violence and
make sure everything's running
peacefully.
And also an amazing fact that I just
learned about a few weeks ago.
There are 200,000
deaths that have happened as a result of
the drug war.
200,000
that's crazier in America.
Know the US and Mexico.
That seems low.
You think that's low?
I thought that was so high.
I mean,
I guess because it's been going on since
Reagan,
so one would think,
okay,
it's more Nixon.
I'm sorry Nixon,
not Reagan.
Right,
but that was like inside the United
States,
but it'd be like how do you classify
like what was done because the drug war,
you'd have to go with all the stuff that
happened in Vietnam with heroin.
I mean how many people were killed
including via.
I think this is just for theu ,
s and Mexico and I think it's tied to
what we were just talking about,
the cartel violence and then people get
caught in the crossfire and they get
their lives destroyed.
It still seems low to me.
Yeah.
And it's over a trillion dollars has
been wasted on this.
I'd be interested in talking to someone
who is an expert,
get Chris Christie on,
but who's a real expert on Mexico and
what happened with the cartels,
the rise.
The cartels because I'm sure there was
always organized violence in organized
crime,
but like what happened where it exploded
to the point where.
I mean,
I was just talking to a friend of mine
who said he won't go to Mexico and I'm
like,
I've been in Mexico,
man,
Mexico is great.
I was talking about a Punto Meta.
You ever go to [inaudible] to me now
it's beautiful.
It's like near Puerto Vallarta.
It's gorgeous.
So beautiful.
But we were.
We were staying at a resort and A.
I was with my family and they have these
golf carts that you could drive around
the resort on and we said,
let's go to the town.
Let's go see what that.
There's a town right outside of the
resort.
Let's go see what it's like.
You go out of the resort in a block.
You hit a military station where there's
men that are standing by on armored
vehicles.
So I said to my wife,
I said,
do you know why they're there?
They're there to guard the resort.
I know that's what this is.
And she's like,
you really think so?
I go,
I know.
So why are they standing here on top of
this?
They have these steel plates with
machine guns.
These guys have flak jackets on and
they're standing there on top of these
military vehicles standing there.
I'm like,
well,
they're ready.
They're on standby.
This fucking thing is right outside the
gates of the four C's.
Yeah,
there to make sure that they protect
their tourism industry.
Yeah,
and that's all directly tied to the drug
war will.
The drug war has had a massive impact on
Acapulco Aco.
Poco used to be the place where
everybody would go.
They said the Vegas of Mexico and they
were trying to rival Vegas and now
that's where they say there's mega
cartel violence.
They don't even call them cartels now,
and I will say there are mega cartels.
They're fighting for more power.
Well then not only that,
there's been some violence where they
purposely killed people that were
staying in resorts to sort of send a
message like,
oh my goodness.
Yeah,
and there's dead politicians to where
they found these mass graves.
Did you hear about that?
Every now and then they'll stumble
across a 200 person mass grave and then
whoever's not being killed,
they're usually being by the cartels.
So some experts.
I've said this is literally a narco
state at this point and I'm curious what
this new guy's going to do because
there's new guys supposed to be
anticorruption and hopefully,
I don't know what his position is on the
drug war,
but I'd be surprised if his position was
not,
hey,
let's find another way to do this
because now world opinion has shifted.
I mean,
in the US,
62 percent of the country says let's
legalize marijuana.
And that's honestly,
I think people are thinking that without
even realizing that there's a giant
spike in crime because it's illegal.
They don't even know.
Yeah,
I agree.
And there are also killing journalists
in Mexico.
They're killing police.
There's a lot of people that are dying
in Mexico because the cartel violence,
you know,
we were talking about that Jamal could
Shogi guy before the podcast started and
how disturbing this whole thing is.
And for folks who don't know what we're
talking about,
fill people in on.
Okay,
sure.
So,
uh,
Jay Mollica Shogi is uh,
a journalist who actually worked for the
Washington Post and he went into the
Saudi embassy in Turkey to get a
marriage license in Istanbul to get a
marriage license.
So for him and his wife and he never got
out,
they killed him,
dismembered him,
used a bone saw,
and then they even went as far as to
cover it up or they had a body double go
in and they gave him a fake beard and
they had him wear his clothes and walk
out.
Is there video of the body double?
There is,
there is.
In fact,
CNN had it.
I know yesterday I was looking at the
CNN video that had it.
Um,
so yeah,
Saudi Arabia,
now brazenly killing journalists.
And I'll tell you what,
you came up with a bunch of different
versions of the story.
Oh yeah.
But why they did it.
Here's the body.
There you go,
there's him and then the guy on the
right with hair.
Why would they have a guy with hair as a
body double?
Think about how much this had to be
planned out to have a body double.
Right,
but why they give the body was bubble.
If you're going to be a body,
double shave your head dude.
The other guy's bald.
That's crazy.
So they didn't even do a good job at
faking their murder,
but it's the worst fake ever.
Yeah,
because the guy's got a full head of
hair.
Yeah.
It's not great.
Not Terrible.
How shoes onto.
He had different shoes.
Yeah,
I mean that's,
that's the worst body double.
It's got dark hair and they're saying
this is the guy.
Look,
he's fine walking around.
No issues at the body.
Double Knot.
A hair double.
I guess.
I mean if you're going to have a body
double shave.
The guy's fucking heads how you walked
in those different shirt and everything.
Oh,
that's a body devil.
So says hair color is different too.
I mean,
he's got dark hair.
This guy's got gray here.
The thing that's driving me nuts about
this is so now at this is getting a lot
of press attention and I'm happy it's
getting a lot of press attention,
of course,
but the reason why it is is because he's
part of the elite class in the sense
that he's a journalist and now you have
the people from the New York Times and
the Washington Post and CNN,
they can relate and they go,
oh my God,
they're killing journalists.
Now.
This is crazy.
Look at the precedent that this sets,
but what people don't know is for the
past two or three years,
Saudi Arabia has been waging a literal
genocide in Yemen and that's not an
exaggeration,
so they've blockaded the.
They're not allowing in medicine.
There's a cholera epidemic happening
there.
Millions of people are sick.
They have people dying of starvation
because they're not allowing in food or
humanitarian aid.
They're bombing hospitals,
they're bombing schools,
they're bombing open air markets,
so they're doing a literal genocide and
that got very little coverage,
but then with this journalist now
finally starting to get some coverage,
but I'm curious what happens moving
forward in terms of how will the US
respond to it,
because as I'm sure you already know
this,
I mean they care more about that
$110,000,000,000
weapons deal that they just had with the
Saudis than they do about the lives of
humanities or the lives of journalists.
Yeah.
The.
The idea of him being really valuable.
It's not.
It's not just that he's a part of the
elite.
It's that there was a conspiracy to do
so that they think came from upon high.
Yeah,
and there was 15 people that they're
saying,
I flew in from Saudi Arabia and one of
them was a forensics expert who knows
how to cover up evidence,
knows what evidence is,
what's like a movie.
It feels like a movie.
The bone saw things that been confirmed.
They know that well at a bone saw.
I heard that now the nickname for him in
Washington DC is a,
what would they say?
Bone saw a solomon,
his name is Mohammed bin Salman.
They're calling them bone saw Solomon or
something like that.
Yeah,
dude,
it is.
The stuff that's going on is just scary
to me and then there's also some
interesting geopolitical stuff happening
around this.
The head of Turkey is now using this as
an issue to try to snuggle up to the US
because he's got ambitions where he
wants to like recreate the Ottoman
Empire and of course Muhammad Bin
Solomon,
he has ambitions where he wants to
dominate the Middle East so you have at
the same time this weird ego battle
between [inaudible] and Mohammed bin
Salman and they're all trying to suck up
to the US to basically get it so that we
can.
We do favors for them and we allow them
to expand and on top of that,
the story's changed multiple times,
right?
It's a story of what,
five times first they said nothing
happened to them,
to him.
Then they said we walked out fight and
now they're saying that he was killed by
people who overstep their bounds.
That's right.
Yeah.
They keep changing the story and there's
also stories that the.
The consulate has video and audio
evidence of the murder.
That's what Turkey saying?
Yeah,
but they don't want to release it
because then people will know how
they're spying on them when they visit
the consulate.
I guess,
so I didn't see that,
but I'll take your word for it.
Yeah,
that was.
See if you can find that.
That was one of the things that was
brought up yesterday that they don't
want to release this video and audio
evidence because if they do,
then other people will know how they're
spying on them when they visit.
Yeah,
I could see that.
I mean they should immediately cut off
the arms,
deal with Saudi Arabia.
No more weapons for a regime that's
doing the stuff that they're doing and
we already knew that they behead people
in the public square for sorcery,
sorcery.
Do they really?
Yes.
Sourcery for witchcraft to see for drug
smuggling that they behead people in the
public square for those things.
Well,
the the drug smuggling,
that's a real problem.
But you don't want any sourcery sourcery
man.
Did you ever watch that movie Dr.
Strange.
Look,
you can get out of strange love.
I think I saw a strange.
I've never seen marvel comics character
that there was a movie in 2017.
He's one of the avengers.
You know who Dr.
St Jude.
I have A.
There's another thing I'm waging.
Jihad on are a comic book based movies
and I'll tell you what,
I'm going to get a lot of dislikes for
that.
But.
So you didn't like black pants?
You know,
I,
I bought a panther.
I did not,
but I racist.
You must be racist Bro.
You got me.
I didn't see what condo forever.
Actually the last one I saw was Batman.
Which the Christian Bale one and just
the voice alone,
the voice alone.
I said,
fuck this.
You didn't like it.
I couldn't stand it.
I said,
that's so fake.
I have to go.
But my brother in law made a good point.
He was like,
yeah,
but he's playing Batman and that's even
more fake than the voice.
So why is it the voice that turns you
off to it?
But I don't know.
I just have a weird thing with
superheroes because we know what's going
to happen.
Oh,
the superior swoops in and saves the
day.
Yay through.
Yeah.
I was going to live.
Give me something interesting.
But the new avengers movie had a lot of
twists and turns like the hall couldn't
be the hulk even when he was getting
angry.
Spoiler spoiler,
spoiler.
It fucked up the movie.
The fucked up the movie because the
whole couldn't be the.
Why the fuck do you have the hall?
Because he can't be the.
Oh wait,
I'm lying.
I saw the hole with Edward Norton.
Was he the hulk?
And one of the movies?
He was the Hawk way back when I saw that
one too.
The Hawk.
Now I call them Buffalo.
Mark Buffalo.
Yeah.
Because why not?
He's a real.
He's an activist,
but he's certainly very vocal.
Yeah.
I don't know much about him.
I just know I call them buffalo.
Why?
Because why not?
It's funny.
I laugh at it.
That's all the matters for you.
That's all that matters.
He's a,
but he's that guy.
He's always tweeting about political
stuff and social social issues.
It seems like.
Very progressive.
Very Open minded or at least very
active.
Sure.
Constantly talking about stuff.
Yeah.
You're not buying it.
I just don't know anything about Mark
Rothko so I can add nothing of
substance.
I can't be the hulk and still be that
guy.
I don't know.
It's one of my favorite superheroes.
So he was the hope to buffalo.
He's the new Hawk now.
He's the new home.
Yeah,
he's been the hulk for the last few
years.
Don't you hate how Hollywood just
recycles the same stuff over and over?
Well,
the crazy thing to me is spiderman,
because it's been like 80 spiderman and
whenever a guy gets famous,
be inspired by band,
he's like,
hey,
look a little more money.
They go,
fuck you.
You're going to make a new spiderman.
Yeah.
But they go with the surefire things
that they know will make money.
Yeah.
And that's the superhero stuff.
Well,
you could definitely relaunched
spiderman and the hulk till the cows
come home.
And I guess Batman too.
But the Ben Affleck,
Batman people like.
Nah.
See that's another one I would never
watch.
Not Ben Affleck.
That's the fucking.
That's the no redoing superman again.
Now I'll think God thing.
You know what?
If I was a woman right now,
be pissed.
Where's the Goddamn cat woman movies?
Huh?
We're super woman.
Why has there not been a catwoman or a
super?
Was the last time there was a cat one
and really very long ass time ago,
there'll be another one.
Give it time.
They need to.
One hundred percent of women were
getting discriminated against in the
world of superhero movies is only wonder
woman.
And she sought his fucking half naked.
Who played wonder woman?
Gal Gadot.
Oh,
that's the Israelis something.
Wasn't she in the IDF Israeli military?
I think she was.
Yeah,
she,
uh,
Marquez.
Who was just here.
Marcus Brown.
He was,
he was showing how she got busted.
She was doing some campaign for Huawei
phones and she tweeted it using an
iphone.
See that?
I hate that man.
I would only push a product that I
really agree with and believe in.
I have a friend who was doing Samsung
commercials and the entire time he was
using an iphone and he was like,
if they catch me using an iphone,
they'll fire me and I don't care if I'm
using a fucking iphone.
So he had his iphone and the Samsung
phone,
but he never used a samsung phone.
All his friends,
he would text everybody or that you
would do.
We'd do on the iphone.
Why wouldn't they just hire somebody who
loves Samsung and is popular because
they could do that better yet.
They should just looks.
It's not like Sam.
This was a long time ago though.
I want to say that,
that this was probably six,
five or six years ago and back then the
phones were not as good.
Like there was a big difference between
the iphone and android phones.
Now there's not really that much of a
difference.
They're both pretty fucking awesome.
Yeah,
and I think that they just hire someone
who's got some fucking integrity and
doesn't lock [inaudible] yeah.
How about that?
Yeah,
I'm kind of married to iphone by default
because I've been stuck with it since
the iphone four and I'm just too lazy to
like because I don't even know exactly
which things transfer over.
If I were to go to a totally new phone,
you know what I mean?
Like obviously nothing almost,
but what about my number?
Would they be able to do that with my
number at least,
or no?
No,
no.
Real.
Even your number would be a giant issue
because you're married to the right chat
or I'm.
I've messaged and that I messaged thing
we were talking about in the last
podcast that I bought a pixel and I
tried to switch over to a pixel from an
iphone and my text messages wouldn't go
through it because everyone was texting
me using an I message and it wasn't
sending it to a pixel.
It was sort of turn to text then send to
you?
Nope.
So that it was just disastrous.
Well,
they're,
they're basically making it incredibly
difficult for you to switch.
So I even called up apple and have them
take out my email from their system
because I know my email is attached,
the imessage,
so take this out for the system,
kill my message,
just kill the whole system.
Still wouldn't work.
I had wound up going back to apple.
You mother fuckers.
I don't know how because I know you've
spoken about it many times so you're
kind of a techie in the sense that you
always get like the new phones and stuff
here for with that.
No,
one of the dumbest techies that's ever
walked the face of the planet,
but I was to say I don't know how to do
with stuff.
I'm into stuff.
I like stuff,
but I don't.
It's like a guy who really likes cars
but as zero idea how they work.
That's prudy.
That's me.
Yeah.
But you still go through the hassle of
ordering it and.
Yes.
Yeah.
That seems like a pain in the ass.
I would use the same phone for 10 years
if I could.
Really?
Yeah.
It's just not something I think of.
What do I use it for?
I use it to text people and every now
and then call and that's it.
I am fascinated by technology and I'm
always interested in where it's going
and what they've got going on next and
now and what's the latest and the
greatest augmented reality is
fascinating.
We were talking about that.
That's really interesting because that's
supposed to be the next big thing,
right?
The how we could see because the phone I
have,
it's a,
not a new new iphone,
but you could do augmented reality games
on so I could look like they're building
blocks in the middle of this table and
play a game where,
you know,
whatever member.
When pokemon was hot and people are
driving down the street playing pokemon
in their car,
they were driving crashing into trees
and shit.
Yeah.
I remember that.
I used when I was a kid,
I loved pokemon.
Pokemon came and went so quick.
The point where everyone was using
pokemon for like months.
Yeah.
And then it stopped.
You're talking about the new one that
everyone's using.
Yeah.
I'm talking to back.
When did we all a game boy?
I used to play it as a kid and then if
you go back,
like I tried to turn it on maybe two
years ago to just see what it's like.
It is the shittiest most basic game
ever.
It's pretty wack.
It's pretty wack in comparison in what
it showed me when people really got into
that pokemon game is that people have,
people are very easily amused and it's
easy to turn them onto some new latest
trend in latest trend being.
What did you have to do jeff,
to go out and get things.
What are the,
when,
when you had to walk to where there were
pokemon who were going to fight you and
then you would,
I think fight them.
And then if you beat them,
you have them in your collection,
your video game,
but not the newest one.
Fight them would you use.
So my understanding is you go into the
APP and by the way,
people can be made fun of me right now
because I could be wrong.
And you're walking around with the phone
and you say,
Oh,
okay,
down the corner,
uh,
and make a right.
And that's where I see a pokemon and
then you go down there and then,
you know,
you fight that pokemon and I guess make
your stronger and catch that one I think
is the way it works.
You sound like you're bored by that
concept.
Yeah.
It wasn't.
I,
I did it like once or twice and then I
was like,
I guess it was also one of those things
where people were losing weight because
they were walking around a lot,
so they were touting the positive
benefits of it.
Like look,
people love walking for miles kind of
cardio compared to the cardio you've
been doing is like absolutely nothing.
They're not like sprinting to get a
pokemon.
You're just.
The Cardio I've been doing is totally
unsustainable though.
I've got five hours one day yesterday,
five and a half hours and then another
hour at night.
Dude,
isn't that going to like hurt your knees
seemed good.
Everything seemed pretty good right now.
Everything's great.
Wow.
So everybody listening right now,
you guys are lazy bitches because he ran
for five hours.
What did you do?
It's not smart.
It's like A.
I used to make fun of people that did
ultra marathons and stuff like it's not,
it's not unhealthy.
Like I'm not doing myself a service by
doing this.
Like my body's like Jesus Christ.
Dude.
Like when I get home at night and I
crashed,
I crashed hard.
Do you sleep better?
Tired.
I sleep like a brick and then I wake up.
I'm like really?
Already get up.
And I'm like fuck,
I got to get to the gym within 30
minutes because I have a podcast in
three hours.
I have to get a solid two and a half
hours of cardio in.
In the morning.
Yeah.
Solid two and a half hours.
Eighty percent.
You know,
so I'm cranking.
I mean it's hard and I'm listening to.
I was listening to stuff to blow your
mind when they were talking about a
flying creatures are quite so quantile
and terror attack titles and the origins
of the quantal.
A myth in as tech Mexico.
And you could watch like the full length
movie of the titanic as your workout.
I've watched a bunch of movies,
like yesterday I watched two solid
moves.
I finally got to see,
get out,
never saw.
Get out was great.
It was.
I really liked.
That was a very,
very good move.
Those again,
movie like,
God,
that girl is so evil.
Spoiler alert.
Second Annual Pokemon go fast draws over
21,000
attendees in Chicago.
So there's over 180,000
people that played Chicago.
Remember,
do you remember when Hillary Clinton is
still played it?
Do you remember when Hillary Clinton
said,
all right everybody,
I need you to poke a mon,
go to the polls.
And then everybody in the audience was
like ditching.
You never saw that.
No.
Now you're,
you're,
you're a progressive but you're not
necessarily a democrat.
Well,
I mean,
you're not necessarily like in support
of anyone who's not a loyal Democrat.
So I describe myself as populous left.
That's how I would describe myself.
Populist means,
you know,
I support the policies that would help
ordinary people.
Um,
and I vote based on the issues.
And so if there's a politician that's
for the policies I'm for,
that's what I'm going to support and
that's what I'm going to argue for.
Um,
so I'm very,
very critical of what we call corporate
Democrats,
which are Democrats that represent Wall
Street and represent big Pharma and,
uh,
the military industrial complex and for
profit health insurance companies.
And I'm super critical of the
Republicans also.
So,
you know,
that's why I co founded a group called
Justice Democrats.
And the whole idea was to basically do a
populace,
left takeover,
the Democratic Party where you get rid
of the corporatists in the party and you
have people who will represent the
working class.
And uh,
we've been pretty successful so far.
They're still 26 justice Democrats were
in the running and they can get elected.
And there were,
here's an amazing fact.
There were four politicians in the House
of Representatives that didn't take any
corporate PAC money.
There's about to be 41.
And that'll happen because of Justice
Democrats.
Our evolution,
which is Bernie Sanders Group,
uh,
the d triple c,
which is another left wing organization.
And basically what's happening is a
people on the left who actually care
about the substantive issues are
standing up and saying,
we're not going to take it anymore.
And we're tired of being lied to by
politicians and we want people who are
going to actually represent us and
represent working people.
You know,
that's a,
I love that.
And I love that approach and there's so
much partisan politics and there's so
many people that are just married to the
idea of being connected to the Democrats
that they're willing to overlook some
really heinous faults.
Any old blue just won't do as Nina
Turner says that,
and I love that phrase,
great phrase because it's so just hacky
and partisan to be like,
no,
I'm on your team,
so are you going to vote for me here?
Let me do some platitudes and some
cliches about how we're stronger
together and we're going to break down
the barriers.
And you know,
it's like,
well,
I don't overtly hate minorities,
so vote for me.
It's like,
oh,
what a low bar.
Give people something to vote for.
That's a great point.
I felt a lot of that during the Hillary
Clinton campaign.
Everybody was like anything but trump.
So we're going to vote for her.
But boy,
if,
let's just be honest,
if you had a viable like Tulsi.
That's right.
Tulsa Gabbert,
great candidates.
You had Tulsi Gabbert and she was
running for president and she's also a
woman and she's also left wing,
but she cares about the issues.
She cares about the issues.
And she's Ernest.
Yes.
Like when you talked to her,
you can tell she just isn't.
I mean she's careful with her words
because she's intelligent,
not because she's deceptive.
Yeah.
And I would vote for her in a fucking
heartbeat.
There you go.
I was just,
we just messaging each other.
She was messaging me about my netflix
special and I said,
run for president.
I want you to run for president.
I mean,
that would be wonderful.
I'm slightly fucking wind man.
I think she can,
but I think she could win.
I'm slightly butthurt about Tulsi
because when I was on your podcast last
time,
I plugged her in talking about how
awesome she is.
In fact,
I think I'm the one who originally
showed you who she was.
Right.
Did you know before?
Maybe in that podcast many people.
So you had heard about.
Well anyway,
she comes on the show are definitely one
of them.
She comes on the show and talks about.
Yeah,
new media is a awesome and there's a lot
of great people out there.
She goes,
Jimmy Dore,
and then there's a pause and then you
move onto the next topic.
And I'm like,
God dammit,
Tulsi,
I've plugged you,
plug me Bro.
I know I'm being incredibly petty and I
don't even really mean what I'm saying
because I would still support her as a
sanitation 100 percent.
So I mean it bro.
This is some salt and it's headed your
way to also show.
Remember now?
No,
but she's great.
She's great.
The issues and um,
yeah,
she's a genuine person.
That's what,
that's what I got out of her,
like what I got from talking to her.
She's a genuine person and man,
I mean maybe it's because she's from
Hawaii and it's just a different place.
It's like,
it's almost like a state that's a small
town.
I mean that's.
Hawaii is very small.
Yeah.
I mean there's a million people in
Honolulu,
but you get outside of Honolulu,
there's only a hundred thousand on the
big island.
I don't know how many Maui has,
but I think it's only got a couple of
hundred thousand.
I've never been to Hawaii before,
but it fucking great.
It looks like a paradise.
I mean the best is alumni.
If you want to go somewhere and just
chill ax,
there's a four seasons and Lanai.
The entire island has 3000 people
living.
Oh Wow.
It's great.
And you get real island.
Hawaiians.
Sure.
They're not like if you go to Maui,
they're wonderful people.
They're great,
but they've been groomed.
You know what I'm saying?
People have taught them how to talk like
regular white people.
Whereas in my alumni they're just
fucking chilled out man.
And they just,
they have that way of talking,
you know,
they talk and you know.
But pigeon is no,
it's a real interesting sort of A.
I guess it's like a dialect of English
he would call it,
but they have really cool expressions.
Like some of the,
they say a lot of things it will choke
like a,
like if you talk about like what guy was
explaining to me how many deer there
were in this one place it goes,
oh,
it was a choke dear there was choked
dear.
So it's Kinda like a broken English with
different words sprinkled.
It's interesting.
Use different words for different
things.
You'd have to be around them all the
time,
but there's also like a,
just a way of talking.
It's very,
very interesting.
That's kind of like,
I think it's called pad wall.
Maybe it's called.
I think it's a people who are Jamaican
who speak in English,
but it's very broken English and
probably real similar.
Yeah.
And they love to say bumble clot.
What does that mean?
Blood clot?
I think mccullough.
I think that's what it means,
right?
Blood clot.
I know they also say blood clot.
They say blood clot a lot.
I think so,
yeah.
That should come up very rarely.
I mean,
unless you're a doctor,
I guess it's a way of saying stuff,
you know,
something's terrible,
but it means motherfucker.
Oh mother bag.
That's what bumper caught means.
Not even close.
The widest God is everyone in this room.
I guess the technical needs,
blood clot,
blood clot.
It's a medical term basically talking
about sutures.
Yeah.
That's funny.
Yeah,
but that flight to Hawaii must be.
It's not bad.
It's five hours from here.
It's five.
I'm coming from New York.
Do you fly here?
You hang out for a couple days and you
fly there.
Interject again.
Top definition on urban dictionary says
it's a cloth rag to wipe ones anal
region.
Oh,
that was my second guess would be the
Bumblebee Bumba cloth.
So bumble clot was some asshole who's
wiping his ass.
He's a cloth.
Like you'd constantly
a douchebag cloth wipes,
but as a,
as a word to replace like fuck or the
asshole or something like swipe right.
It's awesome.
I love that.
I'll be blast waves.
Yeah.
I haven't heard that one.
Oh Wow.
Last time I'm here to ask white.
I haven't heard that in a long time.
That's like Beavis and butthead.
David,
you're such a butt wipes anyway.
You're white.
Yes,
very much so.
That's clear.
People can see that when you look at the
potential candidates for 2020.
Yup.
Um,
who,
uh,
on the left stands out is Gavin newsome.
He just,
he comes across as a little too
politician.
He and smarmy.
That's how he striking me to you.
You don't let them know.
I mean,
I'm sure if I had a conversation with
him and we spoke about the issues,
I would agree with him on most of the
positions,
but I don't know if he really believes
it in means it because he's a
politician.
Politician.
Yes.
There are politicians who I talk to you
when I know that they mean it.
Tulsi Gabbard will be one of those.
Rocana would be another one of those.
We spoke about him on the show as time I
was here.
Um,
obviously Bernie Sanders is another one
of those,
you know,
there's a really interesting politician
and coming out of West Virginia.
Now,
I don't know if you heard about this
guy.
His name is Richard Odetta and he's
running against a Republican named Carol
Miller.
Get this.
He's running in West Virginia is super
deep red,
like big time Republican.
Almost the most republican tide probably
with Mississippi is the most
conservative area in the country.
So this district,
trump won by 49 points.
There's this Democrat Richard Odetta
running.
He's up in a poll against a Republican
by five points.
So.
So you're probably thinking,
how the hell in a,
you know,
a district like that.
Can a Democrat be leading?
And the answer is very simple.
He's populist and he's fighting for
working people and he's run these
amazing ads where he literally gave out
his phone number and one of the eds and
said,
listen,
if you're a constituent of mine and you
have an issue,
call me and I'll tell you what.
If a lobbyist tries to come into my
office,
I'm going to kick him out.
I don't want you in my office.
I don't care about lobbyists,
I care about the people.
And he's running on all substantive
issues.
He's taking no corporate PAC money.
He's for Medicare for all.
So this is a guy who,
you know,
and by the way,
he's a veteran in Iraq and Afghanistan
and he's.
Yes.
And he did vote for trump,
and now he's one of trump's harshest
critics.
And he said,
listen man,
I thought trump was going to be
potentially good for working people,
but it just turns out he wasn't good for
working people.
So for example,
trump ran as an anti outsourcing
president.
He was against Nafta and tpp and all
that stuff.
In trump's first year as president,
there were 93,000
jobs that were outsourced.
That's even worse than Obama.
Obama had 87,000
jobs outsourced.
So when you go through his record with a
fine tooth comb,
even like the unemployment rate being
low,
that's totally misleading because wages
are falling.
So if wages are falling and you can't
just brag about your economy being
wonderful and his tax bill,
83 percent of the benefits of the tax
bill went to the top one percent.
Would you say the wages are falling?
How much they followed by A.
They're not keeping up with the pace of
inflation.
So it's probably about one percent.
So
the point is trump ran as a populist,
but ultimately he was a fake populous.
And he's not really helping to work in
class.
That's why his tax bill was,
you know,
he gutted the estate tax for example.
That's not something that doesn't.
That affects point.
Oh,
one percent of the population.
So Richard,
Oh,
Jetta is this guy who voted for trump
and he says,
hey,
I regretted,
I think trump is wrong.
And basically what he's saying is I'm
the real populist candidate and he's a
really inspiring candidates.
Kind of amazing to see a plus 49
Republican district now potentially go
democratic.
And by the way,
he's living proof of the point that I've
been making since day one.
If you have Democrats who are running
and they actually care about the issues,
I'm on a flight for working people.
That's how you win.
You know,
the,
the real problem is these labels in the
first place,
right?
Like Republican versus Democrat,
like,
yeah,
the idea that we only have two different
distinct parties that are viable options
in 2018,
just so fucking stupid to me.
VR system.
I don't like our system.
I don't.
I like parliamentary systems better.
I wish we had the.
When you said that the wages don't keep
up with inflation and so they're down by
about one percent,
but how much is unemployment up on
employment is down to three point odd
percent and that is good.
I'm not saying that's not good,
but you just have to remember that
that's not a very good economic
indicator because think about it.
This is an argument that was presented.
I remember back when I was in college
and a professor was challenging also on
this notion about unemployment and he
said,
you do know we can create an economy
that has zero percent unemployment.
Right?
And all of us in the flashlight.
First of all,
we didn't know that.
Second of all,
how do you do that?
And he goes,
slavery,
everybody can be working,
but that doesn't mean everybody's being
paid or being paid.
Yeah.
So when to use unemployment as like your
top economic indicator,
it's just a shitty indicator.
It's just not the best thing you can
use.
Right.
Because even if people were working,
it doesn't mean they're doing what they
want to do,
doesn't mean they're being paid a fair
wage.
Dude.
Half of workers in America make $30,000
a year or less is true.
That's true.
If Jamie wants to fact check me on that,
I'm more than happy to be fact checked.
That's dark.
Half of workers in America makes $30,000
a year or less now,
but what about trump's always citing
unemployment rates for African Americans
or minorities that are lower than
they've ever been before?
That could be true,
but what do you think causes something
like that?
Is that something that's a trend that
was established during the Obama
administration that's slowly but surely
moving into the position it's in now and
he just caught that wave or is it
directly a result of the decisions that
he's made while he's in office?
Well,
it does have a lot to do with his tax
bill because corporations are getting a
tremendous amount of money in corporate
profits are through the roof,
so they're hiring.
Right?
That's the link to that.
But again,
we come full circle back to the wages
conversation and remember this is all.
It's temporary because look at what's
happening to the deficit.
For example,
now I'm not a like a deficit hawk where
I think it's such a gigantic issue,
but the Republicans typically run as
deficit hawks
and when you look at the deficit,
it's gone up by 51 percent of all
American workers make less than $30,000
a year.
A lot of similar numbers,
but it's all right around that wire.
So the deficit is skyrocketing and
that's something that's going to
temporarily help,
uh,
those numbers that you were citing
before those,
during the Obama administration,
what was that article?
That's still the case?
Two Thousand 15?
No,
I'm sure it is.
I'm finding all sorts of stuff.
This one's serious says that half of
jobs in America pay less than $18 an
hour.
Can trump help?
This is from August of last year since
it's fall,
right around.
How's the car,
Joe?
It's a house.
A car.
It is a house car?
Yeah.
What was trump supposed to do and what
did he not do?
Like what,
what was he claiming to do before he
went into office?
So first of all,
he said everything at the same time.
So I could give any answer to that
question because I'm curious to just
pick on trump because I was one of the
loudest screaming about how Hillary
Clinton was the exact same thing.
She's a politician who throughout her
career she was on every side of every
issue and trump,
it was kind of the same thing.
But the thing is trump actually got away
with it because I think the way he acts
as a politician,
he acts like he has no filter and he's
just a straight shooter sitting next to
you at the bar.
But the problem is like Rand Paul
pointed out in the debate,
he said,
Donald Trump is a straight shooter
without the truth.
Like he's like pretending to be a
straight shooter.
So it depends on what issue you're
asking you about.
I can tell you what trump said,
you just have to give me the specific
issue you want to know.
Like foreign policy.
You won't talk about that for a little
bit.
Sure.
So on foreign policy,
you know,
half the time Donald Trump said,
and there's so many tweets of him saying
this before he was president,
before he ran that we need to get out of
Iraq and Afghanistan.
It's always the time.
It's so stupid.
Why are we the,
we need to rebuild our own country and
you know,
those are tweets where I read that and I
go,
I totally agree with that.
Donald trump 100 percent.
But then the other half the time when he
was on the campaign trail,
he spoke about how,
um,
you know,
we need to bomb isis to smithereens and
we need to wipe them out.
And those things are kind of
contradictory.
Either you bring your troops home and
you,
you know,
didn't think he would be able to fix
everything really quickly.
Wasn't that one of his premises?
Typical trump bloviating like,
I'm going to be tremendous.
I'm going to be amazing.
It's gonna be the best job you've ever
seen over.
It's not a bad impression,
but you're going to change the tone.
Well,
it's because I'm not doing the full
hand.
You're doing good movement.
The movement skill I have is the
movement.
Joseph Rogan.
I call you Joseph.
What did you think personally when you
saw Kanye with that?
Insane?
He's going to ask you about that to
bipolar rant.
Yeah.
I feel kind of bad for him.
I do and I'm not and I want to be clear.
I'm really not saying that as a partisan
thing because even if Bernie Sanders was
president and Kanye West was in the
office saying the exact same stuff,
I'd still be like,
Whoa,
what is going on here?
Yeah.
Did you burn him up the same way too?
Because I remember when he left those
black lives matter chick that cost him,
but just stepped aside.
That really did cost him.
You think so?
Yes.
Yeah.
People
do.
You can't do.
You can't just take the microphone away
from someone you know.
So here's an interesting question.
Do you think this helped Donald Trump at
all with black voters having cognac do
that,
but how much?
A good number really?
You think so too?
Yeah,
I do.
I don't know.
I don't know because I feel like there's
A.
Kanye West has been disinvited from a
lot of cookouts now as a result of what
he did with trump.
Jamie's on black twitter.
Jamie says not at all.
From what I read,
it did not in black twitter response has
been very negative,
so it was Kinda is really almost in a
sense,
blowing his own reputation on this,
I guess.
I don't think so.
You don't think so?
No.
I think everyone who's a fan of Kanye
West,
who seen him blow up on Jimmy Kimmel and
blow up on all these different people
that have criticized him.
He's.
He's obviously got mental health issues.
When he went on that rant,
I think it was in San Jose.
Is that a concert?
He said I didn't vote,
but if I did vote,
he was voted on trump and everybody went
and then he wound up going into a mental
hospital after that.
Oh Wow.
Checked into a mental hospital and then
canceled his tour.
Remember that?
I do remember that.
That was because he couldn't handle the
criticism.
That's part of it and also part of it
he's legitimately mentally ill.
I mean,
look,
he didn't marry that lady and be a part
of that family because he's thinking
straight.
He's got some problems.
There's something wrong with them.
You know,
he's a genius in terms of music.
He's,
he's,
he's fantastic at creating beats and
songs and hooks.
He knows what the fuck he's doing there,
but he,
he's got a problem and you hear it when
he rants,
when he's ranting and when he's talking
about Ford making dope cars.
We don't use the word dope because we
only use words like magnificent,
admitted,
positive words like he's,
he's making.
He's listening to himself and jerking
off to the noises that are coming out of
his own mouth.
I love.
I loved when you said to the reporter
when the report or pushed back and I'm a
little bit,
he's like,
you just asked me a question.
No,
you can't do that because is like
tasting a fine wine.
It's complex.
Yeah,
exactly.
I thought that was pretty funny.
My read on him,
he's he,
I think part of what he's doing is that
he's a contrarian and when you are in a
place like Hollywood and you're there
all the time,
you're always surrounded by people who
are anti trump.
I think there's something about just
this knee jerk reactionary feeling of
like,
no,
I'm not with you guys.
I'm different and I'm special as a
result of being different,
so I'm a contrarian and I'm going to
disagree with you.
And then I also think there's narcissism
in the sense that he looks at trump and
he really sees himself in trump and that
everybody laughed at trump when he said,
I'm going to run for president.
I'm going to win.
And if you remember a few years ago,
Kanye West said,
I'm going to run for president.
And everybody was laughing at it wasn't
even a few years ago.
It was recently.
Yeah,
he.
And uh,
what the fuck's on guys named Piers
Morgan,
right?
Right.
Right into it on twitter.
Who said you're talking to your future
president?
That's what Kanye said.
Oh my God.
Or maybe it was Harvey Levin.
He said it to you're talking to a future
president actually disliked piers Morgan
more than I dislike Kanye West.
Kanye on that one.
I think Connie's ill.
Oh really?
Do.
And I know he's been medicated.
Yeah.
Remember when he was all Chubby.
When he's on his medication,
you got fat and apparently he got off
his medication and there are a lot of
people,
by the way,
who would hear the point you made and b
would be really angry at the fact that
you think that he's mentally ill even
though I think that's.
I've seen it.
I've seen it all my twitter,
I've seen it on my twitter.
People saying,
oh,
it's just a cheap partisan hacky point.
No,
it's not because he's admitted Lee
mentally ill.
I mean he did say that and the thing he
said,
I was diagnosed bipolar.
Institutionalized.
Yeah.
He spent time in a mental hospital for
being mentally ill and when you listen
to him brand,
this is just my opinion.
That is not the ravings of someone who's
carefully considering the implications
of each word they're saying and thinking
about how to express themselves in a way
that's going to portray some sort of a
clear,
cohesive message is not.
He's not what he's doing.
What he's doing is jerking off.
He's just jerking off with his mouth.
I'm not kidding.
It's just,
it's just like,
let me get it out.
Is the fine wine,
you know,
we gotta we gotta make the dopest cars.
Why can't fly back the dopest cause,
you know.
Did you hear what he said in that same
thing?
Um,
the reason why we got to help Larry
Hoover is because in a different
universe there are alternate universes.
I am him.
I don't think that's correct.
Lyrics,
song lyrics to a song.
Was it something he says that when he's
off his Lexapro?
Yeah.
Oh No,
you ain't seen nothing crazier than this
Nigga.
When he off his Lexapro.
Remember that time in Mexico?
Remember the law that last time,
the episode asking me why the hell are
texting code four times just to say,
don't text me.
Whoa.
Told you four times.
Don't text me,
Whoa,
and we Finna lose all self control,
but you ain't Finna raising your voice
at me.
Especially when we end the Giuseppe to
modern day socrates,
various man.
It's silly,
but I love that,
that nothing crazier than when he's off
his lexapro.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
I do kind of feel bad even though this
is such a,
you know,
like a side show type thing because I
feel it.
I mean the state of the country so weird
that beach simply because of his
celebrity and the fact that the
mainstream media doesn't know how to
keep their eye on the ball.
You never know who can become president.
It could be somebody like Kanye.
You're underestimating trump.
Not The guy who said he could win,
but you knew you would.
And I did too.
I mean,
I set it on my last Netflix special and
one before my last one.
I don't think Kanye West has a goddamn
snowball's chance in hell of being.
Okay,
I see what you're saying.
I don't think anybody that's famous can
be president.
I think what trump did was map some
master manipulating skills combined with
some super human energy that most likely
came from diet pills.
What I think is his ability to campaign,
his ability to maintain his energy and
keep ranting and raving and fucking
phenomenal.
He,
Hillary couldn't keep up with that.
She,
she,
she literally didn't campaign places
because she didn't have the energy.
That's what I was breaking down.
No,
he trump went directly to the rust belt
and railed against Nafta and the trade
deals that destroyed their lives and
Hillary Clinton.
I mean Bill Clinton is the one who
didn't have to.
Yeah,
and she didn't campaign and a lot of
those states because her campaign
genuinely thought like,
oh,
we got those.
Those are democratic lockups,
and then guess what?
Trump ended up winning because of 70,000
votes in the rust belt.
So it directly.
Because of that.
That's why I get so angry when there are
some people on the left who like only
focus on the.
Some of trump's supporters who are
racist and all they want to do is talk
about how bad of people they are.
It's like,
okay,
you could shame people all day long.
That's not going to get them to vote for
you,
but I agree you don't.
You don't need the David Duke's to vote
for you.
That's fine,
but you know who you do need the two
times Obama voter,
who then flipped to trump who was in the
rust belt,
who had his fricking job outsourced.
That's who you need and that's what the
Democrats abandoned the.
The problem with saying that all trump
voters are racist too is you're.
You're creating these very clear sides
and it's a way to whitewash or loss.
It's a way to say,
listen,
we don't have to change in any way
because it's just because these people
are bad people,
so don't blame us.
There's nothing we did wrong.
Blame then.
Whereas if you really were interested in
winning and getting power and
implementing your agenda,
you want to.
If you want to reach whoever you can
reach.
Now again,
I'm not saying you tried to get David
Duke or Richard Spencer on your side
because some people are too far gone,
but 70 percent of the country is not too
far gone.
No.
So you should have went to the rust belt
and you know,
tried to get the two times Obama voter
who then flipped to trump and they
didn't do that.
Well,
I think there's also,
there was some real benefit in someone
like Bernie Sanders,
just like a thing.
There's some real benefit in someone
like Obama socially.
Whereas when you saw a guy who was came
from a single mom who was a black guy
who winds up being the president of
United States,
you just go,
wow,
maybe we're better than.
I thought.
We were like,
maybe we don't have all these
prejudices.
Maybe there's less of us than people try
to claim.
And I think a guy like Bernie Sanders
could have been a real full oil.
It could have been a real.
He could have been a guy that if you
looked at what trump stood for,
trump stood for the outsider who
understands the game because he hired
those people,
he paid those people,
he bribed those people,
and now I'm going to clean up the swamp.
Yes,
drain the swamp.
And on the other side you've got this
deeply flawed woman who's deleted 30,000
emails who's beholden to all the Iraq
war,
the Iraq war.
But how about the Patriot Act?
Warren was spying on all Americans,
which she supported every time there was
a major issue where it was really a test
of character and ideology was wrong.
Well,
and then when you go into her,
her thoughts on gay marriage,
she didn't believe in gay marriage.
So 2013.
Yep.
Which is like,
that is one of the least progressive
things you could ever say.
Like you didn't believe it until 2013.
Yeah.
Like what?
Why not like you think it should be
between a man and a woman.
Like what does that even mean?
It means you're trying to pander to what
you think is the majority sentiment in
the religious country.
Yes,
you're going.
Exactly.
Meanwhile,
Bernie Sanders is the fundamentally the
opposite of Hillary Clinton.
Didn't agree or disagree with him for
the past 30,
40 years.
He's had the same ideology saying the
same stuff.
Yes,
very,
very progressive and maybe he's totally
wrong about some of his socialist ideas.
Maybe it would bankrupt the country.
Maybe some of his.
I don't think it would.
I don't think it would have been.
Maybe it would.
Maybe it would be catastrophic to our
economy to have this guy.
Maybe it would be bad.
Maybe it would be the opposite of what
we're dealing with right now with in
terms of the progression of
unemployment,
where unemployment is at an all time
high and that or all time low rather,
where when you're looking at people that
are doing well in this country because
of some of the things that trump's
implemented,
whether it's people that are getting
lower wage jobs than they would like to
have or whatever it is.
When you look at the numbers,
maybe those numbers would go in the
other way.
So,
but my point is what he represents
though is someone who's not corrupt.
What he represents as someone who's not
beholden to banks,
but he represents someone who doesn't
care about money.
It's not as thing.
It's never been his thing.
His thing has been social justice,
whether it's right or wrong,
at least it would represent something
entirely different.
Whereas with Clinton represented was
corruption with a different taste to it.
So what I would say,
I agree with a lot of what you just said
there in terms of Bernie,
I.
I personally wouldn't use the term
social justice for him because that has
social justice warriors now.
Yeah.
It's a thing on the internet and you
know everybody.
It's basically what I think of when I
hear Social Justice Warrior is over
sensitive college kid with pink hair
who's trying to diy platform
conservative speakers now.
Right?
But that's unfortunate that it's become
that.
Well,
I mean,
listen,
let's,
let's take the way social justice,
let's say progressive ideology.
Okay.
Say that.
But what Bernie Sanders actually
represents in my mind,
and based on his record,
is what he wants to do is make this
country like every other developed
country on the planet that's already
kicking our ass in so many relevant
areas.
So there's this common argument,
which is nothing but a straw man
argument that comes from the far right
where they say Bernie Sanders and his
ideology,
he wants to make the United States like
Venezuela or like Cuba or sometimes even
say like the old Soviet Union.
Well,
no,
if you actually go issue for issue
pretty clearly what he's asking for is a
Swedish or Norwegian type system which
is similar to the u,
except the major difference is they have
universal healthcare.
Some of these places have universal
education.
So,
and uh,
you know,
middle class wages are higher.
So what he's asking for is a better
mixed economy.
It's called social democracy.
He's asking for a social democratic type
system.
It is not post capitalist.
It's not saying let's totally scrapped
the system and let's all,
you know,
act like wear whatever Hugo Chavez or
Che Guevara,
what he's,
what he's asking for is actually,
I would call it moderate in an
international sense because he looked at
the rest of the developed world and he
goes,
man,
these guys are kicking our ass on
healthcare education their ass and what,
what parts of the developed world.
So,
uh,
when you look at healthcare for example,
there's a study that came out from the
Commonwealth Fund which found that the
United States ranks 11th out of 11 when
it comes to developed countries in
healthcare.
So we have worse health outcomes and
it's more expensive and we don't even
cover everybody.
We have 29 million people who are
uninsured.
So when you go there,
there are single payer systems and their
systems beat us in every measurable
health outcomes based on what you have.
Someone who goes to the doctor.
Worse outcome in terms of what happens
once you've been checked in or you would
have to look at the methodology of the
study.
I don't know the answer to that off the
top of my head.
That's a big issue is because we have a
giant problem obviously with our diet,
you know,
and.
Sure I'm not.
I wouldn't deny that for a second.
How much have.
I wonder how much of it is based on
that.
When you're dealing with worse health
outcomes,
like how much of that health,
how many of those health problems are
based on people's personal choices
rather than the healthcare system that
they're operating under.
So that is definitely a serious problem
and one that needs conversation and
needs fixing.
What I'm referring to is stuff that's
more like we have 29 million people who
are uninsured in this country.
We have anywhere from 32 to 45,000
people that die every year in this
country because they don't have access
to basic healthcare.
We pay a per capita,
we pay double what other developed
countries pay and again they cover
everybody.
We don't cover everybody,
so it's very.
We're failing in every measurable way.
Even if you control for factors like
your accurately pointing out.
Yeah.
I wonder what's going on too.
In terms of like,
but we have a very high number of really
fantastic doctors.
Well,
see,
I know people.
That's how I'm gonna.
Address that in a sense.
Please go.
Okay.
So,
um,
if you're a Saudi prince,
you do want to come to the United States
for healthcare because if you're in the
top point,
oh one percent,
you are going to get the best care here.
It's just a brain surgeon or just as a
pediatric surgeon for the average
person,
right?
You're going to want to be in Canada or
Sweden or Norway or Australia or any of
those places.
This is the argument for socialized
medicine versus privatized medicine that
privatized medicine incentivizes someone
to excel.
Someone to be that guy that,
hey,
this guy worked on Lebron James.
Oh,
we've got to go see him.
So you know,
he's the best.
That's a decent point.
And my counter to that is,
and I know Bernie Sanders is as well
because I've seen his bill and he
advocates for a particular type of,
for all system.
You don't need to ban supplemental
private insurance.
In fact,
I would totally disagree with any bill
that says we're now banning private
insurance because you can do a single
payer system where you say,
we're going to have public funding of
public institutions,
or you could do a single payer system
like the French do or the Canadian do,
where they were.
The Canadians do,
where you have public funding of private
entities,
so what you're talking about is,
you know,
hey,
how are we going to.
If there's no competition,
how are we going to get the best doctors
and things of that nature,
and my reaction to that is I'm just
talking about the baseline public
funding of private institutions and
still allow people if they want to pay
extra and go to a specialist,
they could do that.
I'm not necessarily even saying that.
What I'm saying is that the system of
having an incentive for being excellent.
Sure.
Having a financial incentive that causes
people to excel.
Yes,
I would agree with that in certain
fields,
not in other fields.
Well,
I think it's certainly exist in the
medical field and in surgery,
in in many different medical practices.
You find fantastic practitioners here in
the United States because they get paid
substantially for it.
I would argue that the profit motive,
specifically in the realm of health care
has had the opposite effect and has made
it so that we have a disastrous system
now.
If we talk about.
I agree with you as well.
I agree with that as well,
but I think that when you're saying that
they kick her ass and all these other
areas,
like if you say,
I have Canadian friends that come over
here to get operated on and I have and
they have American friends who go to
Canada to get healthcare,
but it's cheaper.
That's why they're not going to be
right,
but they're not going how they get
Canada if you.
So if you were to go to Canada and you
were to get sick,
you just go to the hospital that they
don't charge you.
Even if you're an American citizen,
if you're a citizen.
In fact,
trump was saying back,
he was on like David Letterman show
years before he became president and he
was talking about how awesome the
Scottish healthcare system is because
his buddy went over there and he broke
his arm when he was there and he went to
a hospital in Scotland and on his way
out,
he's like,
how much do I owe you?
And they said nothing.
Get Out.
So if you're a guy in New Jersey and you
fly to Montreal because you're sick,
they'll just take care of you.
Yeah.
You don't have to be a Canadian citizen.
No,
it's pretty amazing.
Don't tell people things just fucked up
because certain things,
listen,
certain things in a civilized society
should be off the table.
It's just a matter of what are those
things.
It's not like everybody agrees with some
level of government.
Everybody agrees,
okay,
we should probably have,
you know,
paved roads and police like that's a
given.
So it's just a matter of let's
prioritize here.
What are the things that we're going to
take off the table and fun with our tax
money and every other developed country
has decided,
well,
healthcare is one of those things.
Let's not be silly.
Yeah,
we've talked about that many times in
this podcast that socialism is
absolutely apparent in many aspects of
our society,
especially firefighters,
police officers.
I mean paying for the street is paying
the roads like we all agree that our
money should be pooled to take care of
these very specific issues,
but then when it comes to some issues,
we get angry and we pretend socialism
doesn't exist at all in this country.
Yeah,
I think medicine is one of them,
but my problem with that is that
medicine is one of the most important
things that a human being could ever
have the in and if you get healthcare,
healthcare can allow you to stay alive.
Like if you don't stay alive,
you can't contribute to the society.
You're,
you're,
you're dying from something that they
could cure.
If you had the money to cure it.
Well this is a giant problem in society.
If we don't address sick and ill people
and injured people,
that's true because then we're not
caring for each other.
Absolutely,
and a medical bills is one of the top
causes of bankruptcy in the United
States.
Can only imagine medical bankruptcy is
just don't exist in the rest of the
modern world.
It's not a thing here.
It's a gigantic thing and a huge issue.
It's weird what we've done and you know
another thing that's weird,
it's what we've done with one of two
countries that allows pharmaceutical
drug companies to advertise on the air,
not just fucking insane congress,
and by the way,
this is why they have like a 15 or 20
percent approval rating.
They've repeatedly slapped down
provisions that would give us cheaper,
but pharmaceutical drugs because they're
allowing the pharmaceutical drug
companies to price gouge us.
Why?
Because they're all bought by big
Pharma.
Yeah,
that's.
That's a giant issue,
right?
What lobbyists?
Getting them out,
special interest groups,
getting their influence out,
getting that kind of money and influence
out of pocket there.
There's a way to do it.
Twenty eighth amendment money out of
politics.
You could do a system that's called
clean elections,
which is basically public financing of
elections where instead of instead of
running and only having a bigger
megaphone,
if you sell out more to billionaires,
a,
you run and you actually have a battle
of ideas and competing philosophies,
and then whoever has the best ideas ends
up winning.
So let's pretend let's go devil's
advocate shirts.
Pretend you're arguing against that.
What if you were some lobbyists for the
pharmaceutical drug company and you were
trying to make a.
I'll tell you what they said.
Well,
I'll tell you exactly what they say,
please.
It's free speech is free speech to take
a $20,000
and give it to the Super Pac that's
trying to get this politician elected
because you're telling me I can't do
that.
Then you're telling me that which means
you're saying I don't have the free
speech to be able to say I support a
private pharmaceutical system.
That's what they say.
They've literally argued that in court.
That's hilarious.
Yeah,
and then the counterargument to that is
at many other people have pointed this
out.
I'm not the first,
but if money equals speech,
prostitution should be legal and murder
for hire should be legal because I'm not
actually hiring somebody to murder
somebody.
I'm just saying with speech because
money is speech that I'm okay with
hitmen.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
the real issue as well would be that
you're not talking about pharmaceutical
companies making no money.
There's still massive amounts of people
that are on medication.
They would still make a lot of fucking
money that just wouldn't make as much
money and how much money are they
making?
And that's where it gets obscene when
you see the actual numbers of
pharmaceutical drug companies rake in,
in this country in terms of what it
takes to develop a drug versus what the
profit margin is.
It's fucking insane.
And the hurdles to get a drug,
any drug.
And there is an issue that they're
dealing with right now with stem cells.
And stem cells have the approval of
that,
right?
Yes.
Because they're,
they're treating them like they are a
drug.
And the conspiracy theory is that
pharmaceutical drug companies do not
want the approval of stem cells for
therapy.
Uh,
was there,
whether it's a,
you know,
umbilical,
all these different types of stem cells
because the success rate is fantastic
and they think that it could potentially
cut down a profit margins.
There are certainly an incentive problem
there.
I mean just the same incentive against
marijuana.
Marijuana sales would cut down on the
sales of pharmaceutical drugs.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And another really gross,
a part of the system is that a lot of
these drugs are actually created in our
universities by researchers and
scientists.
And then what happens is the,
for profit private Pharma companies
swoop in,
they buy up the rights to it for very
cheap and then they price gouge and sell
it back to the American people for a
huge profit when it was the taxpayers
who funded the research in the first
place.
So it's a way where they screw you
twice,
you have to pay for the creation of it
and the research of it.
And then they get the rights to it and
then they sell it back to you again and
Jack up the price.
And then it's even worse than that
because there's this guy,
Alex is our,
who's the head of the head of health and
human services now trump appointed him.
This guy worked for Eli.
Lilly was a price Gouger,
jacked up the prices massively now as
the head of health and human services,
you know what he's in charge of lowering
drug prices.
So this is super transparent,
is hilarious.
Well,
at the end of the brilliance of trump,
honestly,
the brilliance of trump is that he goes
out there and he says like he's populist
and his antiestablishment.
But if you go issue for issue on his
policies,
he is massively pro establishment.
I mean the consumer financial protection
bureau is the perfect example of this.
He picked a predatory payday lender to
lead the consumer financial protection
bureau.
That bureau returned 11 or
$12,000,000,000
to defrauded Americans when big
financial institution screwed them.
And now he's like,
yeah,
let's make that worse.
Let's handcuff that agency and put a
predatory payday lender in charge of it.
So it's all.
It's comical.
Yeah.
It's comical like people wouldn't
believe this to.
I follow this stuff on a daily basis.
I lose my damn mind when I read this
stuff,
but think about your ability to follow
this stuff.
You have so much access to information,
you have so much time on your hands and
this is a main focal point,
whereas the average person is not going
to get this data and I don't blame them.
I'm not blaming.
I'm.
I would never own a shame.
Don't blame them.
They don't have.
There's no.
There's no bandwidth because no way it's
coming in.
Yeah.
What you just said.
I mean,
how many people know what you just said?
Not many,
but that's my job.
My job is to come out here and to say
these things and everybody can check out
youtube.com,
so secular talk,
shameless plug.
I know a and Patrion.com.
So secular talking to other shameless
plug.
I know,
but this is my job.
My job is to come out here and tell
people what I read and what I follow and
bottom line is guys,
and I don't want to come across as
partisan in any way.
Yes.
I like Bernie Sanders.
Yes,
I don't like Donald Trump or Hillary
Clinton,
but my whole thing is I want a system
that is based on common sense and it's
rational and it's logical and it helps
people.
Now Bernie's not going to run.
I think he might think so.
I think he might.
I haven't heard a word about him.
Well,
he has been making some moves behind the
scenes.
Anytime you see a solid station person
representing him,
try to get ahold of us.
Oh really?
Yeah.
They faked us out.
There was a Bernie 20 slash 20 dot.
Oh my.
The other sending the email,
so if you want to get to him,
talk to me.
I don't know him,
but I know people who do know him.
I want to talk to him about his posture.
Fix so many things about the way people
perceive him.
We can move his head from the center of
his chest and put it in a normal place.
Well,
you know,
the funny thing about trump is posture.
This is how a person's supposed to be.
They're not supposed to have been
slashing two men.
No,
you've been normal.
Have Bernie's head is down here.
It's in the wrong spot.
Those trends,
as you know,
look at them.
Look where his head is.
Look at up.
See if you find a picture of him right
there.
His head is way lower than it's supposed
to be.
Your head's supposed to be up here.
See where my shoulders there.
Look at that picture of burning.
Now Watch me.
I'm going to do the same.
This is my.
This is.
See,
where are my neck is sore my shoulders.
Look at that.
It looks like he's doing a little dance
there.
Joseph doing with Jackie Mason.
I call you a joke.
So when I'm trump or Bernie,
that's what I do.
You're not supposed to have your head so
far down on your chest right there.
That's a perfect example.
Has terrible posture.
You know I've said this about trump.
Everybody laughs at his orange face and
is dyed blonde hair,
but I actually think that that does make
him look younger.
The orange face in the blonde hair,
it probably does.
He gives him some sort of life because
if he didn't have,
let's say,
let's say he didn't do the comb over,
he didn't die the hair,
he didn't have the orange face.
People would be like,
oh,
that's like a really senile old grandpa
who was ranting.
There's been people who've done
photoshops and what he would look like
without hair and with white,
with white skin will.
Did you see that thing when he was
getting on Air Force One and it was like
he was a demon dude.
Oh my.
But even there,
he's got some.
He's got and he's got the orange in his
face,
but see,
I would respect him if his hair looked
like that.
When I see him with his hair all fucking
swirled around.
I'm like,
what are you doing?
I'm going to defend trump now,
joe.
That's what I'm going to do.
A lot of makeup.
Just got a lot of makeup.
Dude.
I'm stunned at the dedication he has to
the comb over because this is probably
like an hour long project every day and
he does it every day.
He's probably watching Fox and friends
and tweeting.
As somebody who's doing.
Is there,
do you think someone does it for them?
Is try to find the video of him walking
up the ramp to Air Force One.
Whereas hair,
it looks like a demon.
Yeah,
the skin suit on where it's like it just
pops off.
He's pretending to be a human.
He's rotting from the inside and he's
just barely keeping it together because
that's one,
but it's the image that there's a direct
behind angle.
That's the angle because you see how
there's just a giant bald spot back
there.
He does a really good job of covering
it.
He does.
It's just so crazy.
It's so much worse.
If you got trump hair gift,
it might come up that way.
Go with.
That's it right there,
Jamie.
Here it is.
That's crazy.
Now you could hear the horror movie
noise as that happens.
Like the weird thing is like look how.
Where's the hair coming from on the
sides?
Like how is there so much hair on the
side?
It's a work of our jail.
Like watch it goes up the stairs and
wait for it.
Oh,
there it is.
A wing that wing.
Has he not know that that wing is
flopping around the amount of baldness
in the back of his head.
It's like he's growing hair only on the
side of his head.
Very strange.
Usually when people lose their hair,
that back portion still grows hair at
the very back and his didn't streaming.
I mean it looks demon.
Demon.
So.
So here he go.
Step by step on how to do a trump
haircut.
It looks like some fucking English.
Okay.
I could've been.
I could've been swayed into thinking
going on there.
Yeah.
But I actually do think that this,
it does ultimately make them look
younger.
Helps.
I do.
Yeah,
With that picture of him balled up
there.
Scroll up there,
Jamie.
That picture right there on that same
row.
The bottom rail.
The one next to it.
Yeah.
Look at that.
That's what he would look like.
Yeah,
I looked fine there.
You think that looks fine?
Yes.
I think he thinks he's not 70,
but I think he looks like a pudgy uncle.
Fester then our chance.
He looks like a fucking man.
It doesn't give a shit about his hair.
One of the things is a problem with him
is it's not very manly to spend that
much time combing and spraying.
That's true.
Especially for a billionaire in his
seventies.
It's one thing if you're like 20 and
you're panicking like,
holy shit,
I'm going ball before my time.
No,
you're fucking 70 and you're worth what?
Twenty dollars,
billion dollars or something.
Probably way more now.
Yeah.
He's profited massively from being
inside the White House.
There was some sort of.
Oh,
we can talk about that because.
So you know,
everybody focuses in mainstream media on
the Muller investigation and his ties to
Russia and stuff like that.
I think everybody's missing the bigger
story because the bigger stories that
there are two different emoluments cases
which are proceeding against trump and
for those of you who don't know what
that is in the constitution,
there's the emoluments clause,
which basically says that a president of
the United States cannot take money from
foreign governments because there's a
conflict of interest problem.
If you take.
If I take money from whatever name the
place,
Russia,
Saudi Arabia,
Israel,
you name it,
if I do well,
then
of course you're going to be
incentivized to do policy in favor of
those countries and not necessarily
what's best for the American people.
And there are two court cases against
trump that have proceeded in federal
court on this.
So while everybody's screaming about the
Mueller investigation,
they're missing the even bigger
corruption scandal.
I mean we were talking about Saudi
Arabia earlier,
the Saudi state of trump's hotel and
paid 250,000
or $300,000
and they didn't even fricking stay
there.
So why did they do that?
They did that because they're trying to
make it so that when they give him a
call and say,
hey man,
what about the $100,000,000,000
weapons deal trumps like,
of course,
because he's got more money in his bank
account as a result of the Saudis.
Similar thing happened with Israel on
the way in.
I'm jared cushner and some other people
in the trump administration spoke to a
Israeli officials about how Obama and
Kerry on their way out the door,
we're going to say,
hey,
Israel stopped with the illegal
settlements.
It was just a little slap on the wrist.
It was more symbolic than anything else,
but Israel was calling the trump
administration and saying,
we want you to try to kill this thing,
and of course jared Kushner has taken
millions of dollars from Israeli banks
and he has investments over there,
so there's.
You can't have a president of either
party taking money from foreign
governments because then they're going
to do those governments bidding.
That's a huge problem and I don't see
anybody talking about that.
All I see them talking about is Mahler
and Oh my God,
Russia,
and it's been the only guy that's ever
been president.
That really has been a substantial
business to this extent for sure,
or at least that I know of.
To be clear up.
Maybe there's a way before I knew.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's,
it's dark because everyone knows that
this is an issue.
I mean,
everyone knows,
you know,
and that was one of the issues about
Russia is that he was trying to put
hotels in Moscow.
He did that with rush aided that with
Taiwan.
It's everywhere.
He pissed off China early on because,
and this was maybe not as big of a deal,
but he took a phone call from the head
of Taiwan and China does not want Taiwan
recognized as its own thing.
And so that caused a huge diplomatic
crisis because then China was like,
what are you doing?
You can't,
don't talk to them as if they're their
own independent thing and come to find
out he was working on a deal to put a
hotel in Taiwan.
Yeah.
Well,
what is the deal with China?
Taiwan versus China?
It,
I don't know the detailed history that I
just know that China considers Taiwan.
There's and Taiwan says,
no,
we are our own thing.
Right.
But that's one of those issues where
when Husana we on there because um,
I mean,
I don't know enough about it to give you
my,
to give you an opinion on it,
but it seems to me like China saying I
want that to be ours and them saying,
no,
that seems like a big deal.
Like it seems like you should even
endless.
Listen,
I'm the type of person who says let's
try to work it out in the US at however
we can.
But if it really came to the point
where,
I don't know,
Texas was like,
seriously,
no,
we're leaving now because of reasons x,
Y and Z.
Should we have the right to tell them?
No.
I don't know.
Well,
it was Taiwan was a part of China.
Yeah,
I think so.
Up until.
I don't know,
Dude.
I don't know.
I try to.
Whatever.
I don't know,
something.
I try to be totally up front about it.
I appreciate that.
That part of that story.
I remember thinking that this was,
you know,
people were saying this is unprecedented
for the president of United States to
talked to Taiwan when really China's got
a giant issue with this.
This could cause huge international
problems.
There was a big crisis behind the
scenes.
I didn't get it though.
Well I didn't.
They was.
It was only a story for a day or two,
so I didn't know too many details of it.
Have you been following at all the Ted
Cruz versus Beta O'rourke race?
No.
Would you say Ted Cruz should be voted
out simply because he's Ted Cruz because
that's where I'm at with Ted Cruz.
Well,
he's just a fool.
He's just,
he's so smarmy.
Call them smarmy Ted Cruz.
Well,
one of my favorite parts of the election
was a.
There was a guy with sunglasses on and
he was at some sort of campaign rally
Ted Cruz,
and he was like,
it's over.
Quit.
You're done.
Oh,
this was during the presidential
primary,
sir.
What?
What is the issue that you have with me,
sir?
And he's like,
it's over.
You're a loser.
And it's like the guy who was a trump
guy,
I was like wearing sunglasses.
Like the whole thing was just.
I was like,
you don't know how to handle trolls.
Like,
look at you now.
He can't because he's such a fake gun.
Show fake.
Did you ever see trump manhandle him in
the debate when he tried to bring up New
York values?
I don't remember that.
Okay.
It.
Is it cool if we watch that because
you're going to have a favorite ted Cruz
things though was the excerpts of his
commercial when he was setting up those
commercials and he had all the outtakes.
Mom,
my mom prays for me for hours.
She's like speaking the Fox business gop
debate Ted Cruz and Donald trump
discussed New York values.
Work values on.
Say it again.
Play it,
play it again from the beginning.
Most people know exactly what New York
values
I am from New York.
You're from New York City.
You might not,
but I promise you in South Carolina,
listen,
there are many,
many
wonderful,
wonderful working men and women in the
state of New York,
but everyone understands that the values
in New York City are socially liberal or
pro abortion are pro gay marriage focus
around money and the media and,
and I guess I can frame it another way.
Not a lot of conservatives come out of
Manhattan.
I'm just saying
conservatives actually do come out of
Manhattan,
including William F Buckley and others.
Just so you understand this place.
It's got great people.
It's kind of loving people,
wonderful people.
When the World Trade Center came down,
I saw something that no place on earth
could have handled more beautifully,
more humanely than New York to 110 story
buildings come crashing down.
I saw them come down and we saw more
death and even the smell of death.
Nobody understood it and it was with us
for months.
The smell the air and we rebuild
downtown Manhattan and everybody in the
world watched and everybody in the world
love New York and love New Yorkers and I
have to tell you,
that was a very insulting statement
that,
that could have been handled better.
You didn't like trump's response and was
sloppy.
Just sucks,
but he's just shitting on a whole state
because he's a partisan hack prick.
I understand that the way he handled it
wasn't.
But I got to admit it was a good
response.
That ted such a cunt.
When I'm watching trump stand there.
I'm like,
I hope you get some.
Yeah.
Because he's so fake.
Everything is so preplanned.
And the video you were talking about is
probably an even better example where
he's,
you know,
pretending like he's sitting there with
his kids.
Like,
all right.
Caden did eat your Broccoli.
Well,
Bill Buckley's from England though.
Um,
I guess he lived in Manhattan
afterwards.
I don't know.
Did you ever see the Gore Vidal William
F Buckley debates those?
Uh,
was it called the best of enemies?
What was it called?
I thought it was on firing line his
show.
Maybe I could.
No,
no,
no.
There's a documentary about.
I didn't see that with a thing.
It's called the best of enemies,
but it's a about the 19 sixties debates
between buckling.
Is that best of enemies?
It's great.
You should watch.
I will check that out.
I'm like,
I mean,
he pissed off Buckley to the point where
Buckley called him a faggot and said,
uh,
yeah.
He goes,
Oh,
I forget what the way he said it.
He goes,
I'll punch you and you'll stay plastered
or some fucking shit.
Sock it to the left.
Yeah.
I forget the term that he used.
You know,
Garba Dow lived in Ravello.
He lived in Italy and you know,
he lived in la or Hollywood out of place
in Ravello,
you know,
and he,
I was up there.
I was,
I was put it took a picture from
instagram.
This word,
Gore Vidal used to bank dudes,
right?
Folks respect.
I mean,
I'm a big fan of guava dog.
He's a brilliant,
brilliant guy.
But I liked him.
He got under William F Buckley's skin so
bad that Buckley fell apart during the
rebates.
Oh,
you fucking screamed at him.
He's red in the face.
That's interesting because he was
calling him a Nazi.
Gore Vidal was calling me a Nazi.
Yeah,
I saw 'em on Youtube.
They have William f Buckley versus Noam
Chomsky and you've got the thing that he
said back in the sixties.
Oh,
68 is fascinating to watch that because
if you're really nerdy and wonky and you
love politics,
go watch William F dot Buckley versus
Noam Chomsky because it is.
I love it.
When I was a kid,
I used to watch it and be like,
Oh man,
this is amazing.
He,
he calls the words you queer.
No,
it was more than that,
so I was trying to find the quote.
Yeah,
you could find the video.
He said he would punch him.
Who is this on Netflix day plastered or
something like that.
He said more than the word queer.
Is this on Netflix?
Yes.
Yes it is.
After you got to tell me the name may
not be on Netflix.
It's definitely on itunes.
Yeah.
Maybe you call them a queer,
but whatever it was,
he called him a homosexual slur and then
he threatened to knock him out.
He threatened to sock him or whatever
the fuck he thought,
but it was the red in the face and the
fucking eyeballs twitching and really
was the end for William f Buckley and it
was during an official like debate that
they were having.
It was during the series of debates at
ABC put on.
They put on a series of debates and Gore
Vidal was doing better and then William
f Buckley was kind of a cunt in Gore.
Vidal was mocking him.
He very pompous polymath Buckley was
gross.
It's just weirdly grow,
but it showed how he fell apart from
that statement on.
That was kind of the end of people
taking them completely seriously.
People now look back at him through rose
colored glasses and they act like,
oh my God,
he's such a brilliant intellectual.
Well,
sort of like what they do with Reagan.
Reagan was an embarrassment.
Yeah,
because they used to.
Well,
didn't he?
Late in his time in office,
weren't there questions about whether or
not he had dementia?
Oh,
100 percent.
We'll.
Do you remember during the Iran Contra
debates or the Iran contra trials where
they asked him,
did you sell arms to Iran?
He's like,
I don't remember.
It kept saying,
That could have been a tactic to try to
get out of it,
right?
Oh,
he was.
He was losing it if he didn't hear it
as,
oh,
this is even older than the Chompsky
one.
All right.
Here in the United States,
I happen to believe that the United
States policy is wrong in Vietnam and
the Viet Cong are correct and wanting to
organize it in their own way.
Politically happens to be pretty much
the western Europe and other parts of
the world.
If it was a novelty in Chicago that is
too bad,
but I assume that the point of the
American democracy got up a minute and
the answer is that they will.
They will well treated by people who was
precise them and I'm for ostracizing
people who egg on other people to shoot
American Marines and American soldiers.
Crypto Nazi I can think of is yourself
failing that I listened to you gentlemen
his pornography and stop making any
illusions of infantry in the last war.
That started as a debate on Vietnam and
then by the end they were.
Now that's even seems like a big deal
back then.
It was probably like,
oh my goodness.
I was probably on every a nightly news
show you queer,
I'll suck you in their face and you'll
stay plastered like that's almost like a
rapper dis suck you when you face in
your steep plessy.
Right?
Little bit,
yeah,
a little
bit,
but the documentary is fantastic.
It looks good.
We should definitely go check that out.
It's really good to give me the name
when it's get out of here.
It's the best of enemies.
It's really good because it just shows
you like the.
The time that they lived in it was just
a different world and that ABC was so.
I mean,
they were able to have this on national
television and have debates on policies
and on,
on politics between to recognize
intellectuals,
one on the right,
one on the left,
and this is something that they did on
national television.
It was a big success.
You know,
for the longest time I was,
I was very anti debate and still to an
extent today I feel like I'm anti
debate,
but the reason I am is because I feel
like it's a wwe of intellectual pursuits
where it's more of a show and it's more
about sophistry and it's more about
being quick on your feet.
Then who has the right arguments and I
don't think that's good.
But then the other argument is,
and now I'm,
I'm warming up to this argument,
is that it's such a better way to get
people to watch and listen.
Because when,
when you get really wonky and just have
conversations with people,
many people just kind of tune out to
that because it doesn't keep their
attention.
But what will keep their attention is a
zinger.
So if you know how to deliver zingers in
into debate and you can get more people
to watch and agree with you,
then it's almost almost like a necessary
evil to do it.
So I decided for the political thing.
I said,
okay,
you know what I will debate and I'll
debate mostly because my audience wants
me to debate.
I think my audience likes it.
They Tucker Carlson.
No,
no,
no.
Jake.
You were debated,
Tucker Carlson,
who you,
you're going to divide was going to
debate and culture and culture pulled
out.
Okay.
And then she had the nerve to go on,
good morning la and say,
you know,
these liberals,
they chickened out of debating me.
So she just blatantly lied.
She backed out of the debate with me and
then she goes on TV and says no.
And then she says her though,
isn't that what she,
she's a troll,
but here's the reasoning.
Here's her reasoning.
It was so smug and so elitist.
She's like,
oh,
how many best sellers does he have?
Bitch,
I don't write books.
I don't write books,
but I guarantee you write books like the
book.
I guarantee you I had way more
listeners,
secular talk listeners there.
Then she had an culture fans and let me
tell you something,
even I have people who are very
conservative in my own family and when
they heard I was debating in culture,
you know what?
Every single one of them said,
get that bitch.
I don't like her.
And these are people who agree way more
with her than they do with me.
Well,
she's not really a Republican.
She's a troll and she's a heck yeah,
I don't,
I don't think she even believes what
she's saying.
You know,
in one of the reasons why I say that is
because the way Bill Maher treats or he
laughs and jokes around with it's true.
Sure.
He's like,
there's a wink and a nod with her.
Exactly.
It's a hustle.
I think she's an entertainer.
I think that's true.
And I remember back during the Bush
years,
nobody was more in favor of the Iraq war
and thought it was the greatest thing
ever and would,
you know,
make fun of people who are against it.
And then when trump rose up through the
republican ranks and he was bashing the
Iraq war,
which by the way,
I loved it when he did that.
All the sudden she went on,
she hopped on the trump train.
When all the other candidates on the
stage,
we're not bashing the Iraq war.
So she flipped on this major issue that
defined five years of her so-called
intellectual life.
It's not real.
It can't be real,
real.
She doesn't remember when she was
talking about invading Canada.
It's something about Canada's Canada not
supporting us.
We'll fucking invade them over Iraq.
It was like it was something along those
lines.
Vaguely remember what you're talking
about.
Something like this pitch out of her
fucking mind when she said,
we need to invade a one of these Muslim
countries and just forcibly converted
everybody there.
That was one of the things she said.
I remember that.
It's a real man.
These are the fact that she's still gets
considered for debates.
It's pretty stunning.
I know she's.
She's just disingenuous.
So it would've been.
I would've been screaming at,
you know,
a wall basically.
But the person I knew would have,
it would have been wonderful seeing
everybody says that the corral that lady
into taking the stage with you,
it'd be fantastic.
Can Run circles around her.
I ended up debating Scottie Nell Hughes,
who was big on TV during the 2016
election and she was a trump backer and
now she's on our.
And actually she ended up being very
reasonable.
I'd say we actually ended up agreeing on
maybe 65 percent of the issues and we
had some pr,
some strong disagreements,
but mostly agreeing and I think it was a
very fruitful conversation.
But I don't know if the audience liked
it as much as they would've liked me
bashing culture said,
oh,
the audience probably would've liked it
more.
But it's nice when those kinds of
conversations where people do agree on a
lot of issues,
even regardless of what side they're
supposedly on do take place because it
makes people.
It gives people hope and the idea of
reasonable discourse.
So then you would have absolutely loved.
I was on a panel with Charlie Kirk,
have turning point USA and he's,
you know,
close with candice son.
He's 12 years old.
He's young.
He's not really,
he's probably,
he's my dean.
No,
no,
no.
You're thinking of a different person.
He's a little kid.
You're joking.
I see.
As fairly in your face.
I'm very,
I'm a very literal dude.
So sometimes stuff goes right over my
head,
but we were on hand as they sold girl
scout cookies together that I would
actually believe her.
They did.
Um,
so I was on a panel called,
how are we going to get along?
Charlie Kirk was one of the panelists
now going into it,
I thought,
I'm not going to agree with this dude on
absolutely anything.
But when we got in there,
what I did is I tried to frame issues
from what his ideology is.
So he says he's a conservative.
So I said,
okay,
that means typically you believe in
smaller government.
So I said,
okay,
here's some areas where I believe in
smaller government,
I think we need to stop the warrantless
NSA spying or we're collecting
everybody's information without their
approval.
And without a warrant,
um,
I think that we need to stop the drug
war.
I think we need to,
uh,
you know,
and our invasions of other countries
because that takes a big government and
billions of dollars to do these
invasions and rebuild countries and
things of that nature.
And I even said on the death penalty,
um,
we should probably stop that because
about six percent of the time we get the
wrong people and probably shouldn't be
the case.
And on virtually every one of these
issues.
Charlie Kirk agreed with me.
He even agreed with me on the issue of
Saudi Arabia where,
you know,
I said it,
they
said something like,
oh,
we like law and order and the law and
order president is Donald Trump.
I said,
if you really like law and order,
you'd be against the trump
administration arming $110,000,000,000
worth of weapons to Saudi Arabia.
And Charlie Kirk,
to his credit goes,
no,
I,
I agree with that.
Now the other guy on the panel was an
absolute pack.
He's a Milo Wannabe.
I don't know his actual,
I don't even know his name,
but he,
it was clear he was doing an act and
he's a daily wire,
third stringer,
like he's Ben Shapiro's thing,
but he's a low level guy and his,
I swear,
I swear to you joe,
he was talking about how I'm very pro
life and I need you to know that I'm
very pro life and this is something I
support.
My response to him was,
well,
I'm glad to know that you're against the
death penalty and immediately without
skipping a beat,
he goes,
I'm for the death penalty and the
audience laughs and I go,
well,
if you're going to walk right into my
trap every time,
it's going to be very easy debate now,
isn't it?
What's going on with Milo?
When was the last I,
I should be asking you that.
I didn't even know the dude.
I haven't heard a peep out of him.
And no,
he,
uh,
I think his whole thing imploded because
there was an article that came out and
they have like correspondence between
him and literal,
like actual.
All right.
People were,
they were just kind of doing puff pieces
for them.
That was my understanding of it and he
kind of disappeared after that and
temporarily he was,
he was with Alex Jones.
You did a few shows with Alex Jones.
I was the last I saw of puff pieces
like,
yeah,
like trying to make it seem like they
aren't what they actually are.
Like he was partying with Richard
Spencer and they were singing together
and it was weird.
Yeah,
he's a weird character.
He's a,
he's definitely a weird character but I
actually enjoyed talking with him off
the air and I felt like there's a lot of
what he is.
That's the tricks.
Sure.
And you know,
it's hard to tell.
It's hard to tell because it's hard to
tell like how much of how much of what
you think is theatrical is them being
theatrical when the aunt,
they're on air and how much is
theatrical when they're talking to you
and trying to be endearing off here?
Yeah.
It is hard to tell,
but sometimes you can see it when there
are people who kind of get involved in
this political space is awesome and
really all they want to do is just
become famous and it's like,
that shouldn't be the point.
You should really get in on this
political thing because you actually are
really interested in politics.
I mean,
that's really what it comes down to.
Wood.
That's you.
Yeah,
because I'm a nerd.
That's why I didn't expect my thing to
ever get the.
Honestly,
when I first started,
I really thought maybe in my wildest
dreams I'll get to 100,000
subscribers on youtube and as I talked
to you right now,
we're almost about to cross 600,000.
So I never expected any of this.
I never expected any of this.
And the fact that it happened.
Um,
I'm just grateful for it.
While you're an intelligent guy with
very reasonable points,
so you deserve all the credit that
you've gotten,
but you are also honest like you,
these are your actual opinions and this
is your actual perspective.
The real problem with someone like Ann
Coulter or someone like many of these
other people that I see out there that
we don't have to name
is that they're hustlers.
They found an end.
There's an in for a certain type of
conservative person.
There's an end for a certain type of
democratic persons and in for.
I mean I.
There's pro women,
people that don't give a fuck about
women.
They're bullshit artist.
Absolutely.
We're supposed feminists when they're
just narcissists.
There's a lot of that out there.
There's men's rights activists.
They really only care about finding this
way into a group of people where if you
have their support,
there's just a large conglomeration of
them and you can sort of take them in as
your fans.
Do you feel.
Do you feel like that died down a little
bit?
The men's rights activist thing?
Yeah.
I feel like there were maybe three years
ago it was very big and then now it's
kind of it about it.
That shit from them,
right.
Then they would ship,
you know,
having them be upset at me.
I don't give a fuck,
but my bit was that every men's rights
activists I ever met,
I just want to grab and go,
dude,
we got them all.
Shut the fuck up.
We run everything.
Almost everything.
The whole idea is that.
Not that I don't think men should have
rights,
but it's just we've got them.
Yeah,
and that my thing in the bit was what if
women start to pay attention to the
things men actually did when they
started going,
hey,
we just realized you guys caused all the
war,
every single war ever,
and it's like if you met women caused
all the war would be like,
well we got to kill these fucking crazy
bitches.
The want to do is go to war.
This was in your most recent special,
right?
Yeah.
That's great.
And it was thought out there was some of
them were upset at me,
but like that's a pretty bulletproof
argument.
Like the only men's rights.
Our argument that's legitimate is
divorce laws.
Sure,
I agree with that.
And we're in,
we're in when it comes to alimony and
when it comes to child support and when
it comes to child custody.
Yeah,
totally agree with that.
There are men Nigga fucked over and I
know guys that have gotten fucked over
in that regard and you know what courts
tend to side towards the mother and even
if the most deceptive and if the mother
is,
you know,
they'll say something like he beats the
kids or I think he might've done
something sexual to the kids.
There's women have done horrible things
like that and they've done that to get
more money or they've gotten done that
to get custody of.
They'd done that just for spite.
But this is just.
This is a matter of the courts being
designed to work the situation system
being designed to protect kids and
protect the mother who needs to get
money to be able to take care of the
children because there's a lot of
fucking shitty deadbeat dads.
Now,
if there were no dead beat dads,
if men always paid child support,
then this would be far less of an issue.
The issue is the reason why women can
exploit it is because so many men were
pieces of shit.
Sure.
It.
It created this need for some sort of
some sort of law that set some something
that's set to protect children and to
protect women with.
With that get custody.
Yeah,
and now it looks like the.
With the divorce issue and everything,
the pendulum swung a little too far in
the other direction and there's this
default setting which is actually not
too good for the guy.
The guy you're talking about too,
because I saw that podcast a long time
ago.
I think it was one of the people you
work with on news radio or something
that's just one of them.
That's just one of them.
I know many people that have been fucked
over by by divorce.
Then you know,
and look,
I have a good friend of mine who I've
talked about them on the podcast before.
He has been divorced for 14 years.
He has been married to a new woman for
12 years.
He still pays alimony.
Not only does he still pay alimony,
he pays alimony to tone of more than a
hundred thousand dollars a year to a
woman that he doesn't have sex with.
So he can't retire.
He cannot retire.
This woman has a boyfriend.
She lives in his house,
old house,
my friend's old house.
She owns the house.
They don't have any children.
This is the idea that he fucked her so
hard.
She can't work again.
Like she's not 80 years old man.
I mean she's now in her fifties.
That's almost like indentured servitude.
It's fucking insane to give me $100,000
a year.
He's giving.
Well,
it's tapered down to like,
I think it's now at $150,000
a year,
but at one point he was paying a quarter
million dollars a year and he's paid or
that for 12 fucking or 14 fucking years
now.
Fourteen years.
He's been married to a woman for 12.
He has a family.
He has a family and asked to send money
to this lady.
He doesn't talk to anymore.
Like she can't move on with their life
and if he doesn't,
he gets locked up.
If he doesn't,
he goes to jail.
Yeah,
I mean this is.
And he's trying to go to court and she
fights it and she lives with her
boyfriend and when they send people over
to check the boyfriend puts his stuff in
a fucking u haul,
drives around the block weights and then
comes back.
So what if,
let's say,
let's say he loses his job and he can't
find another job for whatever reason.
He's lucky.
He just always the money no matter what.
And there's no like you can't go back in
front of a court and they can read,
uh,
you know,
take it down or whatever.
That's a good question.
I mean that you'd have to go to court
and a judge would have to agree,
but he's a successful man.
That's part of the problem is he's not
going to be a loser.
He's an ambitious guy,
does really well.
He works very hard.
He works 10,
12 hours every day and he has for ever.
And He's good.
He's smart.
He's good at his job.
And because of this,
he has to pay this woman that he doesn't
fuck anymore forever.
That's crazy,
man.
It's a nightmare.
But here's the thing.
It's like she's not,
she's not like,
she's not in a hospital bed.
It's not like she can't work.
It's like she's,
she's totally capable of making a living
and she now has probably four or five
plastic surgery.
She is the person we were talking about
earlier.
I don't even know me.
Maybe she went,
she fits the route.
Maybe she went the opposite.
I don't know.
But the idea that my friend has to pay
her and every now and then you know,
we'll,
we'll talk about it.
I'm like,
you still have to pay her.
And she'll just go,
oh my goodness.
He's fucking.
I mean,
got a family.
He's got a wife and he has children with
this new woman and he's happy and he
still has to pay.
What does that $2,000
a week,
2000 plus a just an absolute nightmare
areas.
So here's a check for $2,000.
Lady.
I don't even know anymore.
So speed.
I guess this is somewhat related to what
we're talking about here,
but what did you make of the cabinet
thing?
Um,
this is my,
I mean,
I've,
I've spent a lot of time over the last
week paying attention to it.
Oh really?
This happened to a little longer.
You just caught up on it,
you're saying for awhile it was like,
this guy is gross.
This is gross.
I don't want.
When the main thing was happening,
we just weren't paying attention to it,
but over the last week of paid a lot of
attention to it and here's my take on
it.
Um,
one of,
one of the things that got me was um,
well,
one of the things that got me is it
seems like most of his,
most of his life and his young life,
that guy was fucked up.
He was drinking a lot.
Did you see,
read the yearbook?
Did you see the year?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And all the stuff about like on the
calendar,
like he had his calendar and then when
things were scheduled,
beers were scheduled.
Very bizarre.
That's very busy.
And he was so like frat boy,
Douchey,
like all this stuff he said was very
cliquey.
Yeah.
And he also lied.
Oh,
endlessly.
Yeah.
Dashawn.
That alone is all I need to know.
He said,
he said goofing is farting and goofing
of course means fucking.
Yeah.
Everybody knows that that's nonsense.
So He's a liar.
So,
and then he perjured himself and saying
that he didn't know.
And by the way,
the Democrats didn't even mention
perjury.
They just,
they just kinda laid down.
They just kinda laid down.
My whole thing was,
I think it was a gross spectacle.
And I,
I,
I honestly,
I thought that even the hearings
happening,
I felt like it was a little bit of a
clown show because it's like,
here we are the most powerful
organization in the most powerful body.
This government,
United States government where we're
having this hearing and we're talking
about drinking.
That happened in the 19 eighties.
It just struck me as so silly.
But at the same time,
the thing that you know,
I was screaming about,
and I might may have literally been the
only person in the country screaming
about this stuff.
I actually went through cavenaugh as a
judicial record with a fine tooth comb
and I disagree with him on basically
every decision he's ever made.
And that's not an exaggeration.
He's for warrantless NSA spying.
He rules with corporations 87 percent of
the time.
He said that all of Obamacare is
unconstitutional.
He ruled that the EPA can not regulate
greenhouse gas emissions.
Uh,
he even goes as far as to say Donald
Trump might be able to pardon himself.
So.
And that's,
I mean,
that's like,
that was one of the reasons why they
think that Donald Trump was getting him
in the first place.
But that's the thing.
But that's also part of the Patriot Act.
Yes.
That's like the end of modern
civilization type shit because you can't
have somebody above rule of law that's
like a dictator for.
That's craziness.
So the thing that drove me crazy,
Joe,
is that here you have
on all those important issues.
Did you hear a single democratic
politician bring that up in the
conversations,
but it wasn't at all about the
accusations.
It was all about the act.
I'm not saying you can't bring up the
accusations at all.
I think you can bring it up,
especially because some of them seem to
have decent amount of evidence on their
side and seemed very measured and
reasonable in their comments so you can
bring it up,
but it just annoyed me that there wasn't
like a two pronged strategy and trying
to defeat it because the Democrats suck.
Joe.
They suck because it just to suck.
They suck in the end.
They don't think there's any pressure to
not bring up those issues?
No.
Well,
maybe.
I guess maybe a little bit,
but Chuck Schumer,
for example,
cut a deal with Donald Trump just
recently and he let them approve like,
I forget the exact number.
You guys can fact check me on this.
Six or 10 different.
A Jew of trump's judges,
he cut a deal to approve them so the
Democrats can go back home and campaign
for the upcoming election,
but it's like,
hey,
douche bag.
The reason why you guys are struggling
in elections is because you don't stand
for anything,
so those people,
why don't you to fight on those judges
because you're not supposed to agree
with those judges because that's the
Goddamn opposition party.
Yeah.
I don't understand why they wouldn't
bring up all those issues that you
talked about before.
Here's 15.
See I even formations of 15 trump
judges.
Look.
Yeah,
and see this is my problem with them is
that you could give them an issue like
take legalizing marijuana that in
exchange dems facing reelection can go
home to campaign.
How ridiculous.
And this is what the Democrats do,
Joe,
is that like we were talking earlier
about marijuana.
Sixty two percent of the country now
wants legal marijuana.
The only democratic politicians talking
about it is Bernie Sanders and maybe a
handful of others.
And if they ran on these issues,
and I can name a thousand others,
like raising the minimum wage,
uh,
ending the wars.
If they run those issues,
they'd win,
but they just don't do it.
Yeah.
Well,
I agree with you.
The cavanaughs take on all those issues
are pretty fucking vile.
Yeah,
but it did.
All those things disturb me.
What disturbed me most about what they
were talking about in terms of his youth
wasn't that he did bad things in his
youth.
It's that he's lying about them now.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
If he said,
look,
when I was 17 years old,
I was stupid,
like many 17 year olds and I drank,
but I never raped anybody.
Did stupid things and maybe I acted
insensitively and maybe I said some
things that I shouldn't have said
because I was a fool.
I am not a fool anymore.
And now I'm a judge and now I think it
would make a great supreme court justice
if he could say that,
but he didn't.
He got angry and like same like I've
watched the video of him saying,
I'd like beer.
You like it.
He's asking a senator,
do you like it?
Do you like it?
I like it.
Like,
what does that fucking mean?
You're talking about you as a teenager
when it's illegal to drink you stupid.
Fuck.
And he also did a little slight of hand
there and said,
oh,
most of the seniors at the time could
legally drink.
Yeah.
Why'd you say most of the seniors?
We're not talking about.
Most of the seniors were talking about
you.
He wasn't legally allowed to drink at
the time,
but you're right,
you're exactly.
The problem
was the lies.
He could've just said exactly what you
laid out there,
but he didn't do it.
Which again speaks to his credibility
and it's kind of funny that the one
woman,
if he did do that to her,
the one woman who turns out to be a
professor,
it's hugely progressive,
super liberal university who it's almost
predominantly women.
Like if you looked at how many women are
professors at the university and how
many women's.
I think it's something like 79 percent
of the women are 70.
Nine percent of the students are women
at the university.
And in some large number of the
professors are women as well.
Yeah.
Well,
well at least one of the allegations
were bullshit against him.
You know who it was,
right.
Michael have a naughty.
That anti-trump grifter who just wants
to get his fucking name in the media,
he,
he represented some woman and there's
thousand holes in her story,
but this asshole,
because he wants to get his name in the
spotlight,
he,
he adds on to the other accusations and
some of the other exhibitions do have
merit any.
He blows up the whole thing,
so now the Republicans can turn around
and go,
look what we got here.
Bullshit example.
So it's all bullshit.
I think he did it.
Now Sharpton.
That guy is a scumbag.
And by the way,
he was just a political one where I was
and he's listened.
He came out of nowhere.
He came out of nowhere and now he's
talking about running for president.
Who the fuck are you?
I saw someone say that they think you'd
be great.
Yeah.
Well they say,
whoever said,
that's a fucking idiot.
It was bill Maher.
Well,
Bill Maher,
can I,
you know,
I used to like him,
but he's gotten progressively worse and
worse.
No Pun intended,
on using the word progressive.
I think it was him on Sam Harris,
his show.
I'm thinking about it now.
I think it was him talking about his.
His argument was,
oh,
because I want a Democrat with balls and
have an naughty.
Has Balls.
Yeah,
but the problem is he's a piece of Shit
grifter I'm talking about.
He was gonna make a presidential run.
Apparently on extra.
They just posted this and why is the
fucking mainstream media allowing this
guy?
They're letting.
They're giving them free airtime,
Joe.
Well,
this is the problem with the media.
Why aren't you giving serious people
free air time?
Why aren't you giving fucking economists
or professors who are experts in social
policy give people who know something,
some airtime.
This guy's obviously a grifter.
Well,
they're giving him free air time because
people are going to pay attention to the
idea that he's going to run for
president because he was representing
stormy Daniels and stormy Daniels.
Fuck the president and this whole big
fucking clown car circus event is.
It's something that people tune into.
It's basically an episode of keeping up
with the Kardashians,
the presidential issue,
and imagine that's your guy.
Like,
Hey,
who are you?
Oh,
I got famous because I represented
stormy Daniels,
like,
oh,
what a fucking genius.
You are.
Good Gal.
And she,
uh,
she,
she fucked a guy and she wants some
money.
The fact that that's like stormy Daniels
has been in the news more than the
genocide in Yemen,
which our weapons are being used to
carry it out with.
I saw a fucked up meme.
It's,
it's stormy Daniels is now going back
to porn because trump makes America work
again.
That's actually true by the way.
She's good.
She's going to strip clubs and stuff.
Well,
I know she's been going to a strip club.
She got arrested.
That was fucked up.
She got,
there were these police officers who
were super pro trump and they went to
one or a strip club events and they just
arrested her piece that she did
something that was upstairs bullshit.
And I'm no stormy Daniels Fan,
but you don't use that.
So that was a political arrest.
It was just a fucked up thing.
The whole thing is so gross.
You know what?
I went down in the rabbit hole on
recently.
Mgk versus m and M.
Have you seen this?
What was mgk and.
Okay.
I was in the exact same boat as you like
three weeks ago.
Okay.
Jamie's all excited about black twitter
now.
Okay.
So,
so m and M,
everybody knows legendary rapper,
one of the best rappers of all time
broadly considered that.
Um,
he did an album where I guess he
mentioned mgk because mgk who's another
rapper years ago had tweeted something
about his gun caching gun Kelly.
Oh,
what are you mgk in me,
Bro?
I thought was mgk.
I don't know,
I'm not trying to be cool.
I thought that his fucking name was.
I did see that.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
did you see the rap videos where they
went back into a terrible.
Both of them.
Both sides killed them.
So I got sucked into a vortex where I
was watching all the commentary on it.
No,
it was,
but I,
I was fascinated by people's take us
takes on it.
When people were saying,
Oh man,
murdered him.
And I listened to it,
I was like,
this is terrible.
Well,
with Tara was killed,
shot terrible,
or was wrapped.
Devil terrible.
They both suck.
Rose.
He's not a rap guy,
so this doesn't.
I do like and I'm only marginally a guys
like Redo.
Okay.
Yes I do.
I listen to a lot of reps that just felt
like it was just.
I actually liked the mgk song though.
Like the beat.
Okay.
It was a good beat.
Congratulations.
But he like ruined his career as a
result of this.
No,
that's what I look at.
The light that this like on Youtube,
it's like fucking 50 percent dislike.
Why do you pay attention to that?
I,
that's why I told you I got sucked into
a vortex of it.
You can't pay attention to that.
That's not representative of whether or
not the guy has a career.
I bet it boosted his plot.
I mean that was the argument people said
maybe he did it because even though he's
this photo is sort of what ended it.
He posted this thing like I when sort of
with this large crowd behind them,
but he didn't tell them that he was
opening his opening for fall out boy.
And this is followup boys crowd.
Yeah.
He told them he took off his jacket.
At the last second,
so everyone turned around for a picture
and then he got booted after this by the
entire crowd.
Did he know he got booed?
There's a video of it.
But did they actually,
one of the bullying videos was fake.
I do remember that.
I don't know if it was this one,
but I do know that he had a Hoodie on or
something and he took it off before this
picture.
So they didn't know that you had that
shirt on,
which is the cover of m and m's album.
And you're right,
it was fallout boys crab,
which is kind of a weird weasely move of
this guy to do.
I'm sleeping.
Joe's Joe doesn't care about the rap
game.
Wants to.
Not that I don't care about the rap
game.
It's this fucking.
These distracts are so lazy that he took
the distracts,
get me interested again.
That's what it took to get me interested
because I remember back when was fifty
cent versus jd kiss and I fucking loved
it.
But when I was a kid,
I fucking love that.
The J dot Rapp was one of the best.
Uh,
I thought it was the best battle rap
I've ever heard.
Well,
what about Jay z versus non?
So that's a classic,
that's a classic.
And that did nothing but help both of
them.
Right?
A kid help nas more than help.
Jay Z dot I think.
No,
no,
you think Jay z versus not has helped.
Jay Z,
black twitter.
Look at it as an expert over there.
He loves it.
He gets crazy.
He'll come back and tell you who's
dating,
who they run the twitter and all the
memes of oil comes from.
They run twitter.
One 25 percent of twitter memes and
everything is coming out of black
twitter.
Twenty five percent.
Did you do the math?
It's a known fact,
Bro.
I'm like,
Bro,
I didn't pull it out of my ass.
Okay.
Um,
speaking of social media,
have you seen all these purges recently?
There's a new round of it that just
happened.
No Way.
A purge,
800 or 800 or more accounts were purged
from facebook and twitter and they're
all,
almost all alternative media accounts.
So some of the sites are snowflakes.
Was One,
I think on facebook there's another one
called anti media that was purged there,
an antiwar media thing,
free thought project is another one.
Take this and there was cop watch,
police.
The police was called.
So basically what they're saying is it's
such a bullshit argument.
They said,
oh,
the reason we pulled this is because
it's inauthentic behavior.
We're pulling these accounts because
there's inauthentic behavior on those
accounts.
What does that mean?
I don't know.
That's the point.
And they never clarified.
So what I think it means is,
hey,
these are,
you know,
these are alternative media outlets and
we want to get rid of them so we're just
gonna get rid of them because facebook,
I know met with the Israeli government
and Israel told them,
hey listen,
if you're gonna be in our country,
you're going to get rid of certain
accounts and facebook when right along
and said,
sure,
we'll do that with China,
with Google.
Right.
But now I think they're doing that in
the US now.
I think there,
yes.
I think they're working in cahoots with
the US government and so you have all
these alternative media counselor,
specifically antiwar.
What have you.
Anticorruption some of these are okay
and they're getting purged?
No.
The argument was inauthentic behavior.
That was one of the reasons they cited
as to why they got rid of this
inauthentic behavior.
Does that mean that they're talking
about instances that they're
misrepresenting?
No,
I think it means more like bots.
That's how I interpreted it.
It's like,
oh,
you know you're posting it and you're
directing people to your own,
you know stuff and everybody does that
on facebook and twitter.
Is it possible that that's what was
going on?
I don't know.
I'm just asking is it possible they were
using bots and perhaps directing them
towards revenue creating sites or.
My.
My whole thing is why shouldn't that be
allowed?
Well,
I'm not saying they shouldn't be
allowed,
but is it possible that they were using
stories that were taking place in the
news,
distorting those stories to get people
to click on things that would have links
to ways that these people can make
money,
so instead of it being some sort of
political
activism website that really was just a
revenue generating bullshit site that
was trying to drum up artificial
outrage,
is that possible?
I think for some of them it's certainly
possible,
but certainly not.
Certainly not for the free thought
project.
What is it free thought project?
It's another one of these,
I think they described themselves as
like an antiestablishment or anti
corruption,
you know,
thing where they cover all these stories
related to government corruption,
kind of like a wiki leaks type thing,
except they don't do the Wiki leaks,
does more of the original reporting
stuff and they'll just cover it after
the fact.
And how many facebook deleted them?
Facebook,
I think I read it in,
if,
I think there was an article in the
Guardian,
Jamie,
if you're interested in pulling it up,
it's um,
facebook and twitter purge 100 sites.
So when you mix it was like,
I think it was mostly on facebook,
like 600 or so on facebook and the 200
or so on twitter that they did and a lot
of them were like one of the accounts
that over 3 million people who liked it.
Now,
the free thought project,
what has their response been to this?
I don't know.
I don't because I only saw the original
article.
I haven't seen anything after it,
you know,
this is a discussion that I was having
with red the other day.
We were talking here it is.
First they came for Alex Jones.
We told you you are next.
We're,
oh,
we were next.
We were.
This is on their website,
but they did cover it in the Guardian
and some other outlets in case anybody's
thinking that this is bs.
Yeah.
That's so good.
It is a scary time because you see that
this can impact,
you know,
really anybody who's not toeing the
line,
if you will,
like a police,
the police.
Are we really gonna like,
do we really think that they pulled that
down?
Not for the obvious reason,
which is that you're sowing discord and
the police don't like it as part of its
purge.
Facebook has removed the pages of
several police accountability watch dog
critic groups,
including Copblock,
the free thought project and police the
police.
They've also apparently severely
restricted.
The activity for the photography is not
a crime page.
Huh?
So you think they're getting pressure
from law enforcement?
I don't.
I don't know,
but I never usually believe in a smoke
filled backroom conspiracies,
but they're starting to get hard to
avoid because there's so many of these
things.
When,
um,
scroll down please.
Here's what we need.
Look at this and how does this poem,
and again says first they came for Alex
Jones and info wars,
but I wasn't race baiting,
transfer spirits.
He cultivated Clemson,
murdered children,
new town.
Where are hoaxes and admitted in court
that I'm just an entertainer who makes
shit up,
so I said nothing.
Yeah,
they're just trying to be flippant about
how Alex Jones was pulled.
The problem was once you bought into the
principle of Alex Jones being polled,
well then what you're saying is people
who are executives at these companies
can willy nilly decide whoever they want
to pull down.
Now my answer to that has always been we
should take twitter,
facebook,
these giant social media pages.
They can still be private companies,
but we should regulate them like their
public utilities.
You know?
That's the argument that Ari and I were
discussing,
100 percent.
That's the only answer because you need
to default to free speech.
Now I'm not saying if somebody doxing
somebody or somebody directly
threatening somebody and stuff like
that,
there should be a process set up where
you can ameliorate that and do it
quickly.
But having said that,
like people forget man,
the Acl,
you used to defend the KKK in course,
or would already brought up.
Yes,
and they said,
hey,
in Skokie,
they said,
hey listen,
we know we don't agree with these
people.
We think they're heinous.
We think they're terrible.
We think they're dead wrong,
but they have a right to say what
they're saying because once you get rid
of it for them,
what people don't realize though is that
these things will always come back
against people who are powerless and
marginalized.
It's not like when you censor,
everybody gets together and we all go,
okay,
so it's just the Nazis,
right?
Yes.
It's just the Nazis.
No,
first of all,
who's running these?
You know,
these organizations,
obviously they have their own opinions
and their own vested interests and their
own power dynamic issues and they're
going to take down whoever threatens
their power now is are all these
organizations still up on youtube and
twitter and Google?
I don't know.
To my knowledge,
the only one that totally got pulled
down everywhere I think was Alex Jones.
He still has
website here.
It says all but proving the case.
This was a coordinated attack by the
tech giant community.
Shortly after the purge on facebook,
twitter follows suit,
wiping out our profiles on there as
well.
They gave absolutely no reason for the
suspension.
Said we had closed the freethought
umbrella,
had close to 6 million followers.
Wow.
Isn't that crazy?
And they just decided overnight.
What's crazy is I didn't even hear
about.
Well that's why I'm here.
I appreciate you.
I mean I had heard that it was 800
different pages,
but the way I'd read it,
and I unfortunately don't have a lot of
time and I was flipping through
something I'd read that it was a lot of
um,
anti-police pages.
Some of them were anti police,
but I think a lot of them were not.
A lot of them were antiestablishment
anti corruption,
like they've always had it out for
wikileaks.
For example,
Wiki leaks as well.
I mean,
you've had mike pump hale,
one of the top trump administration
officials because it says they're like a
nonstate terrorist actor.
Think about that.
That's nuts.
That is because basically what they do
is what discharging reporters should
say,
hey,
here's what the bad guy,
here's what the people in the government
are doing and this is the stuff that
they're keeping secret that they
shouldn't keep secret,
and our government goes,
oh,
that's terrorism.
Now,
when twitter or one of these people,
one of these organizations,
bands,
something like the free thought project,
do they make any statements or they just
remove them
all?
I saw what was on the Guardian article
and on the Guardian they said it was
inauthentic behavior was the reason why
they were pulling them and maybe one or
two other things that I'm forgetting at
the moment.
That is a fucking weird statement.
I know.
Authentic behavior.
Yeah.
It's fucked up man,
because they could just do it to
anybody.
That's the point and that's what's so
scary.
Well,
that is what scary,
right?
Is that there are private companies and
these people are allowed to post on them
until they decide they're not allowed to
post on them because they violate their
terms of service,
but when your terms of service with are
that open ended inauthentic behavior,
like what the fuck does that even mean?
So
they just.
They leave the terms of service
purposefully vague so that they can get
away with knocking off wherever they
want to knock off.
It's just weird that they all agreed
that facebook agreed and twitter agreed.
Like what would be the incentive of
twitter to follow suit?
Will it be the incentive smokey back
room given to.
If you had to speculate.
Okay.
What do you think would be given to them
that would give them the incentive to
want to pull a site that's kind of like
Jack Dorsey guys seems pretty socially
progressive.
I think they are meeting just like what
we said,
we know they did this with Israel where
they pulled down pro Palestinian human
rights pages to allow facebook to
function in their country.
They said you have to do x,
Y,
and Z dot.
I think that there are meetings with,
I don't know exactly who it is,
our intelligence agencies,
law enforcement,
FBI,
I don't know.
Somebody like that.
Maybe CEO's of various corporations
where they say,
hey man,
listen,
these people are problem.
These people are problem.
These people are a problem.
Let's do the right thing here.
I would like to hear a contrary
argument.
Well,
I don't know.
I would like to know immediately.
I would like to know like what is the.
What is the contrary argument?
Is there anything that we're missing?
If we want,
we could try to find the guardian
article and read what they said,
what twitter said,
what twitter and facebook says,
see if you could find that,
you know the Guardian article.
It's not coming up and pulled it off the
internet guardian.
What did,
what was the headline?
Searched it and went on news and like
there was no articles from the Guardian
by the way,
the only two.
The only two things I found,
the only two things I found it on rt and
the Guardian and nothing else,
which is why you didn't hear about it
because mainstream media didn't talk
about it because guess what?
These outlets,
oftentimes our competition to mainstream
media.
What the fuck man that is.
So the Alex Jones thing is really like a
test run almost pretty much searching on
their website,
on the Guardian website,
rethought project that's using google to
do it and the top article is something
about food in 2013.
Well when we get off here,
I'll do a search and we can see if we
could find a statement.
Yeah.
But when we get unfair is not helping
all those people.
The newest right now they saw it.
They saw the article from the free
thought project and that says the same
information.
We just don't have the exact statement
from twitter and facebook on it.
That's the only thing.
See if you can just google statement
from twitter that wasn't involved.
The free thought that wasn't in the
article.
They just threw it in the middle of the
It was like facebook and twitter purges
accounts for,
I don't know if it's an inauthentic
behavior in the title,
but it was an article somewhere,
so you really think that there's some
sort of smokey back room deals where
they say,
listen to you,
you guys are making tons of money.
We've got a bit of an issue here.
Let's work through this.
This is what we want removed.
These people are causing us a bunch of
problems.
I don't know,
but I,
I do know they did that in Israel.
I do know that they do that in all these
countries where the government say,
hey,
in order to function here you have to do
x,
Y,
and Z,
so why wouldn't they do that in the US?
That's what I would say to that.
But what groups would want the free
thought project or police the police
removed?
Well,
you gotta remember a lot of these.
So the police accountability groups,
I mean it's pretty easy law enforcement.
What would want that removed?
Right.
But do you think law enforcement has the
kind of pulled to go to twitter and not
like the,
you know,
whatever.
The Police Department in Toledo,
but if the FBI maybe.
Sure,
or the CIA or whoever,
major law enforcement,
general law enforcement,
the thing that people kept going to with
Alex Jones was Sandy Hook,
Sandy Hook.
He said children didn't get the sale.
You don't have to defend Alex Jones on
the merits of that point because he's
dead wrong.
On that point,
when you're descending is the principle
of letting somebody speak.
I understand.
Yeah.
That's not what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is there's no thing that
they're going to on this,
so it's like there's already been a
precedent set.
They could just remove people.
So they removed him.
They got this here.
It got sloppier.
Yeah.
Well it got more clandestine because
there's no.
There's no big smoking gun.
There's no nothing.
It's just all of a sudden the yanked.
Yep.
That's right.
And again,
no major mainstream media outlet in the
US reported on it.
Our is Russia today.
Jamie's got exact article.
Okay.
There's this image of all media by
facebook is pushing back just to
beginning censorship in state.
They may cite the Guardian article in
this article.
I was looking more about because I saw
this article that came out,
it's us pushing back today from today.
This is from today.
Today I saw a different article on the
same.
Scroll down and make that a little
bigger please.
Hm.
So that.
So people were starting to catch onto
it.
Scroll left so we can see.
There you go.
The latest appearance of an apparent
censorship of political speech online us
based tech giants this month shut down
hundreds of user accounts,
some belonged to wells to abis.
Alternative media outlets with hundreds
of thousands of followers,
like the free thought project or
anti-media senior fellow with German
Marshall Fund leading think tank,
advocating us global supremacy seems to
have at least partially taking credit
for this.
It says in quotes,
Russia,
China,
and other foreign states take advantage
of our open political system,
Jamie.
Fly set.
They can invent stories that got
repeated and spread through different
sites.
So we are just starting to push back
just this last week,
facebook became began starting to take
down sites.
So this is just the beginning.
Okay.
So what they're saying is that these
websites have been infiltrated by people
from China and Russia.
Is that what they're saying?
But scroll back up again,
please stop.
It said China and other foreign states
take advantage of our open political
system.
Russia,
China.
So that is.
That is somebody from the German
Marshall Fund,
a leading think tank,
advocating us interest,
saying that because we're so scared of
Russia,
Russian,
Chinese,
Russian and Chinese infiltration.
That's why we got to pull down.
So in other words,
they're saying,
hey,
maybe these accounts like the free
thought project are run by people who
are trying to destroy America.
So we have to pull them down.
Exactly.
And that's beyond a preposterous
argument.
This is what they're saying.
They're saying they can invent stories.
They get repeated in spread through
different sites.
So we're just starting to push back just
this last week.
Facebook again started take downsides to
this.
Just the beginning.
So they're,
they're blaming the influence of Russia
and China and that they're saying that
this is their excuse for taking down
these pages because these pages are
being compromised by foreign agents.
It's the oldest trick in the book to
say,
Oh,
these foreign entities or sowing discord
in the United States,
so therefore we're not going to allow
this dialogue to happen.
In fact,
I remember they blamed Russia for black
lives matter facebook pages during the
2016 election,
but what's fucked up about this is
there's not even any smoking gun.
There's.
There's no evidence.
They just say it,
right?
They're not,
but they're not even pointing to a
specific example.
Yeah,
that's right.
Any example where,
yes,
you're correct.
Scroll down and see if there's anything
in this that makes any sense.
According to the account,
flying complained that any person with
an email and set up an account on social
media and potentially reach a wide
audience,
you're predicting a long global struggle
to fix the situation.
Jesus Christ.
Oh,
great.
He started his career as the US
political circles as an advisor to
George W dot Bush administration is
always trust those people.
Also a foreign policy and national
security consultant for this Senator
Marco Rubio.
These are the geniuses who should
regulate the Internet,
right?
These guys who've been wrong about
everything reliably.
Well,
this is the thing,
if you could just say,
oh,
the Russians have influenced this,
the Russians are a part of this,
the Chinese,
okay,
pull it.
It's hacky and it's partisan and it
actually works for on the left and the
right.
Sometimes it works on Corporate
Democrats and people who want to blame
Hillary's election loss on the Russians
and it works on you that played that.
Let's hear him talk because you're a
little bit of it.
Can I go to the bathroom real quick?
I'll be right back
here.
Principles values as one of our greatest
strengths and therefore one of the best
ways to weaken us.
So I think that that's one of the key
things to understand here is Putin's
acting actually out of weakness and why
we jamie not come to understand or at
least the consciousness in this country
does not necessarily view Putin
aligned with other strong men figures.
This has been a long running problem in
American foreign policy.
This is not just a problem that started
with President Donald Trump.
I served in the Bush administration.
President George W dot Bush tried to
form a relationship with Vladimir Putin
to get certain things to advance us.
National Security.
President Obama tried the same thing
with is reset of Russian,
a US Russian relations.
So it's not unusual that you have an
administration that maybe doesn't
necessarily view Russia as the threat
that it is.
Um,
I think the politics of this,
the public opinion right now,
it's very interesting because you've
actually seen a shift over the last
several years.
More Democrats now actually I think
actually view Russia and Putin as a
threat,
uh,
compared to where they were still here.
But boy,
this gives you,
it just leaves a bad taste in your
mouth,
is the idea that these people are just
deciding to remove pages and there going
on television giving these interviews,
saying that it's because of Russia and
Putin without any evidence.
Oh,
so maybe they didn't share the evidence.
You've got to say something,
man.
I mean,
if you want to be.
If you believe in a free society and you
believe in freedom of speech and freedom
of expression and you censorship censor
people are shit,
Bro,
what's going on here?
I'll fix it.
I would only go with that.
And maybe that,
um,
what happened?
Nothing.
So it's something that they don't have a
fix for the,
for the way that it's happening.
So if you show the evidence,
then you're,
you're literally showing the criminals
how to how to do this and it could just
run more rampant and they got to plug
more holes.
Well that would be the devil's advocate
position,
but in order to take people down,
the thing is if they're doing it and no
one's pushing back,
you're just going to be able to do it
with anybody that disagrees with you or
anybody that's going to be an impediment
to your political campaign or anyone's
getting the way of anything you're
trying to push through.
And then this is,
this is a giant issue with people that
have that kind of power that can
influence facebook or twitter.
And if that's the case,
and look,
we don't know,
we haven't talked to Zuckerberg,
we haven't talked to Jack Dorsey,
we don't know who's,
who's pulling strings or who's asking
them to do things or what evidence they
presented to them.
But that's just very uncomfortable.
It's very uncomfortable to see that guy
talking and bringing up Russia and Putin
because people bring them up.
Like they're the man,
you know,
this is what's the brushing poot
they're,
they're interfering with our democracy,
interfering with our issues here in
America and they,
they want to ruin democracy and bring
our country down from the inside.
Yeah.
It was like,
um,
the Internet went through a phase of
like just totally free and open wild
wild west type thing and now it looks
like they're trying to reel it back in.
And it's like,
that's the viewed as the public square.
It's supposed to be the,
these social media outlets which are so
gigantic and so powerful that this is
now the public square.
So to be able to censor people in these,
in these forums should be considered
unconstitutional,
coordinated,
inauthentic behavior.
Oh,
you found it.
You found articles spamming
hm,
but again,
the like the websites that they actually
pulled down,
that totally destroys their argument.
Even if you buy into the premise that
these are,
this is a good reason to pull somebody
down.
I mean some of the people,
the pages
they pulled down were so well
established and there are of course not
inauthentic in any way.
It's people who are running these pages
that really deeply care about these
issues and want to get this news out to
people.
Fuck,
this is a good quote here.
Drawing the line between real and
inauthentic views is a difficult
enterprise that could put everything
from impartial political parody to
genuine but outlandish views on the
chopping block and find us.
There are politicians in the US.
This happened during the debate between
Ted Cruz and Beta O'rourke all at the
exact same time with the exact same
hashtags.
There were pro ted Cruz.
Things tweeted out at once,
so at that is their bots that they
bought to help Ted Cruz win the
election.
That's election interference.
That's inauthentic behavior and nobody's
talking about pulling down those
accounts.
Look at what it says here in a statement
posted online newsroom.
Facebook says it,
purge those pages because they're owners
were using fake accounts,
sharing the same content between
multiple pages and linking to add
supported websites.
It calls ad farms,
so what that doesn't even is that even a
controversial,
but this is where it gets interesting it
says,
but what the social network calls spam
the owners of these pages call standard
procedures for operating on facebook.
Yeah.
That was like.
I don't even think if the argument from
facebook is correct that there really is
a reason to pull them down and go.
It says here,
nearly all the page owners contact by
the Guardian,
say they use backup or fake accounts.
Hmm.
Along with their real ones,
they do it in part to protect themselves
from being targeted by political
opponents and having their real accounts
end up in facebook jail.
Reverse press,
a left leaning news site whose facebook
page disappear yesterday,
so this is on the left and the right.
They're censoring people because you got
snowflakes on the right.
There's another one right wing news that
was pulled down.
Stop scrolling.
Please,
but,
but look at this,
this is really interesting there w,
so they're admitting to disingenuous
behavior though they're using fake
accounts to protect themselves were
being targeted by political opponents.
Well it's,
but that's if that's the case,
they are violating facebook policy.
So I've seen this on twitter.
I know people who have gotten their
accounts banned on twitter but they
create a new account and they stay on
twitter and that's technically a
violation of terms of service,
but it also is something that I don't
think is religious at all.
Right.
But there's a big difference between
someone getting banned and then starting
a fake,
a second account.
This is not that they're,
they're using multiple accounts at the
same time and some of them are fake.
Look,
I'm not,
I'm not justifying their being banned,
but I am saying that they violated
certain procedures and they did so in
order to public publicize their ideas
and they did it to try to make their
ideas more,
just more project them more have have
more,
more bandwidth.
But according to facebook,
should you not be allowed to have like
three or four accounts where you tweet
the same stuff or post the same stuff?
Because it seems like you said though
what facebook said,
if you scroll back up to the beginning,
scroll back up at the beginning please.
That's part of the top.
The top,
the top,
top.
See what it says.
A coordinated inauthentic behavior and
spamming.
So they were spamming and that does
sound like coordinated inauthentic
behavior.
If they have a bunch of alternative fake
sites and fake pages that they using to
spread their stuff.
Look,
I'm not saying that they should have
been.
This is,
I think better would be to say,
hey,
you can't do that.
You've got to remove these fake pages
that are publicizing your ideas and just
have your real authentic page.
But what they're saying is that they're,
they're leaking to add farms and that
they use this to publicize their pages
and that everybody does it.
Everybody does it.
You're not supposed to do it.
So why wouldn't they pulled?
So let's say the free thought project
have three or four other things where
they were posting the same stuff under a
different name.
Why would you not pull down to three or
four other things and leave up to the
free thought project?
I think they're saying [inaudible] the
free thought project violated their
terms of service.
You're not supposed to do that.
So you don't want them to do that.
I don't know.
See,
here's the thing.
Would they have pulled the free thought
project down if they hadn't engaged in
any of these forbidden behaviors?
My opinion is I think yes,
maybe that's what I think may be,
but that is gross.
You're not supposed to do that and I'm
not saying that they should be pulled,
they shouldn't be pulled,
but maybe they thought this is what they
have to do to get the word out and maybe
facebook is like,
hey,
you fucks are spamming and you're.
You're linking to these ad farms and
these ad farms have been known to be
influenced by Russia and China and all
these other organizations.
You're doing it just to promote your
sites.
But we're saying that we can't allow
that kind of behavior.
It just strikes me as very strange that
when you have examples like the one I
just gave were maturing the ted Cruz
Beto O'Rourke debate.
They all tweeted the same thing at the
same time.
It was obviously paid for by some right
wing think tank.
You never hear the story of something
like that.
If it's benefiting us politician or
something.
Like when Mitt Romney bought like a
million fake followers on twitter and
the 2012 election,
you never hear about like,
okay,
we targeted that.
It's always like,
oh,
it just happens to be these independent
alternative media outlets.
They're spreading the information that
the government doesn't want people to
know.
Well,
it could be that these people are
saying,
hey look,
everybody does this.
We're going to do this.
And they're saying we don't like them
there.
Oh,
and look,
we caught them doing something we.
We don't allow.
Yeah,
let's sweep them.
But that's possible.
Is it possible that they wouldn't have
been removed if they hadn't done this
shit than not supposed to do?
It's possible,
but I don't think it's likely.
I don't know though because here's the
thing,
how look if it's only people who've
engaged in these forbidden behaviors
that get removed,
then facebook has a very good argument,
but if facebook is saying this,
but then people were removed who are
straight above board doing everything
the right way,
just have their own page posted
information on their own page and they
were never removed.
But these are all political and
alternative media which is interesting.
So they were targeted.
Yes.
Alright.
So they're targeted,
but in the targeting them,
they found a bunch of shit that you're
not supposed to do and that's what got
them removed.
I think that there is a good argument
that facebook could make,
which is very much a nuance troll terms
of service argument,
but I think it's more of a veneer or a
facade than the real heart of why they
did what they did.
But again,
that's just my opinion.
I'm not stating that as a fact.
I agree with you.
I mean,
surely what they should have done,
especially given the popularity of these
sites,
is warn them and say,
Hey,
you've got to stop doing this because if
you don't,
we are going to remove you.
You were violating our terms of service.
You are linking to add farms and you
have posted from multiple fake accounts.
Stopped doing that.
Just use your one authentic account.
We support free speech.
That's what we both like,
right?
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
I mean it could be also that they feel
like the right wing sites do this.
We have to do this too.
This is how people do it in 2018 is how
you really get the word out.
That true.
Yeah.
You know,
I just,
I've found it interesting that it was
all alternative media and political
accounts and or left.
It was just the main thing that seemed
to be the connecting tissue through it
all was relatively antiestablishment.
It's gross.
It is gross,
man.
Have you been following what's happening
with Iran at all?
No,
I have not.
There's a little bit of ramping up of
tensions now.
So of course we pulled out of the Iran
deal,
the nuclear deal.
Um,
I don't think that was a good idea
because according to the IAEA
International Atomic Energy Agency,
they verified that six different times.
Iran was following that deal and trump
pulled out of it.
Anyway,
that hurt are,
you know,
diplomatic talks,
if you will.
And then this story broke a few weeks
ago,
the International Criminal Court.
So Iran sued theU ,
s and according to the International
Criminal Court,
they said,
hey,
we can't,
we're not allowed to sanction them when
they allow in humanitarian goods.
So our response to that was to say,
fuck off International Criminal Court.
We're not pulling out of the
International Criminal Court.
So talks about basically totally broken
down.
And now the fear is,
um,
that we could be on the road to war
because we have neo-con John Bolton,
who's in the trump administration,
has always wanted a war with Iran.
We have Mike Pompeo who also wants war
with Iran.
And um,
it's just,
it's not a good situation because we had
a pretty solid deal there and now it's
more likely Iran gets a new if they want
it,
um,
and the tensions are ramping up and if
they blocked it because Iran is
economies imploding right now and if we
block their oil exports,
that's when you know that we're about to
do some sort of regime change action
over there.
Dude,
I have to end this unfortunately.
Do you have anything happy to say before
we wrap this up?
No,
I don't.
Listen,
I'm sorry.
I have 34,
10,
a secular talk.
Give out your youtube address again.
Sure.
It's youtube.com/secular
talking on twitter on at Kyle Kalinsky
Chi.
We've got to do this more often all the
time,
man.
When are you going to be back when you
don't know,
but next time I'm back.
I'll definitely be on.
Thanks Bro.
Appreciate you man.
Thanks man.
Appreciate you too.
Appreciate it.
All right folks,
we'll be back.
See Ya.